Like it it actually does not require bad
faith or malice or anything to think
that food is a pedophile at all.
>> 77% of Jews in the United States vote.
Dan doesn't even vote.
>> Dan suffered the greatest oral loss of
all time. It it was really just food
shops escalating for not really any
reason. I got to be to got to be totally
real here. Why are these married men so
concerned with who wants to be friends
with Destiny? That is a great question,
isn't that? Is a great question. All
right, guys. We are going to skip over
just sort of like the start of this food
shop stuff. Okay, the very start of this
food shop stuff we're going to skip over
a little bit because basically all that
happened was food shops and Zip Zip.
>> Two people, it's honestly like
>> in terms of
>> they're incredibly similar in terms of
the way they talk and like their ability
to convey their ideas. They're actually
incredibly similar.
Um,
but basically food shops and zip zip.
Destiny leaves his stream
and starts playing his debate with Desh
Duza to sort of like just babysit his
chat and fill time while he's not there.
Food shops and Zip Zip join the Discord
live channel using their perms and just
start talking to to each other over the
top of the video, but no one can hear
them properly or the video properly when
it's happening. So the whole chat starts
spazzing out. There's a vote to ban them
and they get banned from DGG. Later on,
Dan takes I think Dan takes away food
shops perms or foods joins a stream and
screams and Destiny takes away her perms
or something like that.
And so uh that's sort of where we're
jumping in here. And then there was a
little discussion on anything else
between Dan and Mutton about food chops
where then food shops joined to
challenge them. And we're going to watch
this food shops talk about this whole
thing. Try and talk about the pedophilia
again and cover that. Yeah. During an
intense match of arc raiders, apparently
Destiny lost because she joined and
started [__] screaming. Okay, got
you.
So here's the conditions of the peace
deal. Okay. No, here's the condition of
the ceasefire
and and I'll I I'll just say real quick
um what is all
>> Wait, is this the right one? No, this is
the wrong one. Got the wrong one. I need
this fod first.
>> Here we go.
>> I was like, you know, maybe
>> around here is when
>> uh I think that
>> I think the discussion of the the DG
drama
>> whatever crazy usually starts
>> action.
Where's the beginning?
>> Someone joined at the same time like
that. He's right.
>> Oh, right here. Right here. Right here.
Okay. Right. Okay.
>> Um,
>> what's my take? Uh, critical support for
Dan in casting out this [__] freak.
Okay. Critical support for Dan in
casting out this freak. Time for you to
go homeress. You will be homeless.
>> Okay. I want to very like I want to very
much clarify. Okay. If you don't believe
me, then like it is what it is. All
right? If you don't believe me, I can't
do anything about it. Okay? Back in the
day, um when I was like um an early
content creator, uh I made a lot of edgy
[__] content.
And um I specifically honed in on like
the concept of pedophilia and stuff like
that. Right now, I'm also made a lot of
jokes while trying to cover the topic at
the same time. And that basically caused
Lolly one. Obviously, you know, making a
lot of edgy jokes while also covering
the topic probably isn't the best idea.
Um, obviously, right? But, you know, the
extremely edgy jokes that I have made
back then, um, like it's it's not like
there's anything different from these
jokes from or like from the things that
Mr. Graph said or like Destiny have
said. So,
I guess the way I kind of look at it is
like back in the day, um, I was a naive
new content creator and I did not know
how to navigate the space. So, I thought
that being the most provocative was like
the best way to go. So, I made a lot of
jokes that would get me a lot of
negative attention. But obviously at the
time I was naive, right? Like looking
back it was pretty stupid. But um
but while I was like actually covering
the topic itself, right? Um pedophilia.
Okay. [__] I need to say PD cuz I don't
think YouTube likes it. I don't think
YouTube likes it when I say say that.
Okay. It's fake background. I got you.
Yeah, I figured it out.
Um,
so obviously because of that, right? And
then I also admitted at some point that
I unironically consume lolli. So if you
don't like the fact that I consume
lolli,
you're free to leave. Okay. Um, you know
it like that is just a part of me, you
know, like it's just some dog [__]
Gotcha game.
>> Yeah, I have kept two songs, but yeah, I
assume she still talk about the
pedophilia,
>> guys. I can't change. I'm a [__]
total freak who godsly talks about the
bizarre sexual attractions. I can't
change that. Yes, you can. Yes, you can.
Attractions or anything like that,
right? But I don't think I'm a
pedophile. I really don't think so. Um,
like I'm generally attracted to just
like women in their 20s, right? Women in
their 20s to uh yeah, just in their in
the 20s range. That's it, right? I'm 26.
So,
>> no pedophile has ever said this, guys.
So there's no possible way.
>> I can never imagine like going after
like a kid IRL. Like it's just not true,
I guess. But then at some point, you
know, I addressed the allegations so
much. I addressed the allegations so
much to the point where it become like
the Stryson effect where it was like the
more I addressed the allegations, the
more I have to like repeat it over and
over again. And that basically was like
lolliggate one, right? That was lolly
gate one. And then it moved on to logate
2 and logate 3. Lgate one was like um
when uh Twitch pole at the time was
dogpiling me and they were trying to
cancel my career. Okay, like cancel my
early content creation thing. Okay,
that's it. Not career. There's no
career. Um
and I think Chudlo Logic was the one
that really blew up the thing and then
Counterpoints actually debated Chudlo
Logic on the subject of me at the time
like years ago. Um,
so, so that's what formed counterpoints
like early kind of [__] like towards me
or whatever, right? You're not attracted
to milks. No, I find milks extremely
unattractive. Okay. However, at the same
time, like I don't know. That's just my
preferences, you know? Like, what can I
say? Yeah, I like beach babes. Like that
kind of [__] Okay, whatever. Um, but
like
>> Yeah, your preferences are
>> not like the body type, not the actual
archetype. Okay, [__] Never mind. No,
not like that.
>> Do you have OCD? I do. Um, I think at
some point, um, because I felt so guilty
about consuming Lolly, um, I saw a
therapist for it. And this is something
that people will also bring up as well.
And by the way, okay, I'm only going to
address it this one time because I don't
like stryend affecting like this thing.
Um, basically what it is is that I
became extremely extremely anxious and
about like consuming hentai, okay? And
lolly [__] in general, okay? I became
paranoid because I was like, "Oh my god,
what if I'm a bad person for consuming
this? What if I'm like a PDF for
consuming this?" Okay, so I was like,
"Man, I am Oh my god, I'm like
gaslighting myself, right?" So, I went
and saw a therapist. I paid like $200
per hour, by the way, like out of
pocket. $200 per hour because I was like
I was genuinely at my lowest like in
terms of um mental health.
So, I went to go see the therapist and
then um the therapist was like, "Okay,
this is what you need to do to avoid the
compulsions because your compulsion is
not to
>> jerk. This is going to sound really
awkward, okay? But I promise this is
going to make sense because when guys,
you can't make sense. You have to not do
the compulsions. You have to not do the
rituals. Okay? You have to avoid them at
all times. The compulsion was to not
jerk off to Lolly because I would think
that I am a PDF, right? So obviously
what the therapist who is a OCD
specialist told me to do is that you
need to do the opposite of what your
compulsion tells you to do, which means
that no matter what situation it is, and
I'm not joking, and this is a really
funny part, okay? I mean, it's really
funny or really weird, okay? They'll be
like, "Oh, you know what? Just do it. Do
it without guilt. do it without shame,
you know. And then at some point I got
better. I finished the whole thing and
I'm like, you know what? I'm better now.
>> This story has changed so much in the
years I've been hearing it,
>> right? But obviously like even though I
got done with all of the therapy
treatments or whatever, like it still
didn't make anything else go away. Like
it still didn't make the drama go away
or whatever. Right. So ultimately, I
think Late 2 was me beefing with Keeles.
So Keles was like digging up a bunch of
like the old crash outs that I was
having during Late One. Was that how you
found out OCD? No, I No,
>> I've got a whole playlist whole playlist
on my channel of the of the food shops
videos. All classic stuff. All classic
stuff. Should remind people. Should
remind people. Some people might have
seen that. Go back. Go back and watch
those if that catches your interest.
>> I've had I I think I've always suspected
I have OCD for the longest time as well.
Um, but like that was when um that was
when Keeles was like beefing with me. I
know. But when Keeles reconnected her
bridge with DG, that's when I also
initially got banned from DG because I'm
pretty sure Call Matra was the one who
um said Keles sends her regards. I
something really cringe. Okay, basically
Keeles was calling me a PDF while she
was actually probably grooming actual
children into becoming trans. It was
super weird. Okay, on her Discord
server. So it's like nice projection
there. Okay.
So um yeah uh that was with careful. The
third one was when I was having another
like debate session with like
commentary. Basically commentary was
holding in on me during that time and it
was their turn. It was their turn to try
to cancel me. Okay. So just notice how
each of these different communities have
tried to have their different turns
trying to cancel me, right? Essentially.
So, first it was Twitch pole or what's
left of Twitch during that time cuz it
was really dying and and it's pretty
much dead now at this point. Like Twitch
is pretty much dead
>> been dead.
>> The second one was Keo's community and
that was when she was doing the rape
allegations uh against like her exartner
or some [__] during that time and that
was insane. That was absolutely absurd.
And that was also like um that was alo
crazy because again I'm one person, one
incredibly tiny like magnanimously tiny
content creator who's being dogpiled by
an entire community right straight out
the gate. Dogpiled. This is all this
year. No, two years ago. It started two
years ago. Dogpiled right by Twitch and
then I was dogpiled by Keles and her
community. Um during this time um she
was pulling like 3k to 4k concurrent
viewers.
>> Yeah. This retail
like spearheaded by counterpoints and
chloic's community right a little bit.
>> So and then the third one was
commentary. So it was like now recording
it was um the commentary community who
wants to have their slice of the pie.
Now it became pretty popular to cover me
I guess like at some point. Like at some
point it just became kind of popular to
cover me like in that little space. So
that's where I got my infamous status
from. Um and now and now it seems like
DG is finally having their turn. Okay.
Um in terms of coming after me for like
this exact same things. So whenever
somebody tells me whenever somebody
tells me, "Oh, like why don't you
address it? Why don't you address it?
Why don't you address it?" It's because
we've done this before. Like it's
Groundhog Day, you know, when you do the
same action over and over again, but
then you keep on resetting back to like
8 a.m. or some [__] right? So like
what's going on is that it's Dan Gi.
That's true. But like what's going on is
that like for the first one, I explained
myself. I tried to explain myself. I did
a really bad job at it. And then second
time and the third time, right? And I
got better and better. I got better and
better at explaining it. I thought they
knew already. Only some only some knew.
But now it's like being pushed to the
forefront, right? But I But anyway, it's
like at some point like in the past when
I got these allegations, I was crashing
the [__] out. Like I was a total crash.
>> Yeah, thanks for explaining Groundhog
Day. I was confused. There's going to be
a lot of cringe that they're probably
the same thing keeps happen. Okay. in
order to like shame me based on [__]
that I said like one to two years ago
which like again these are like
prehiatus times because after I came
back from my hiatus like I would argue I
just became a straight up a different
person because I like joined the USPS I
delivered mail um I don't know I got a
lot of like outdoor experience and [__]
so like it basically kind
>> Dude this is like literally this might
be the most Jimmy line of the stream
>> but just so easy to pass over
I'm like a totally different person now
I got I got so much life experience
working for the USPS PS for 3 months.
Why not streaming for 3 months and
working for the USPS? That would not
turn you into a completely different
person. I I don't know how to break this
to you. You're like 25. It would not
turn you into a completely different
person going for 3 months to work a
wagey job. That is not going to
completely alter your psychology. That's
just not the case. That's cope. And you
act the same. Um
but
um yeah, just know that you know it's a
lot of stupid [__] But then anyway, I
will now explain, okay, for people who
don't know the context, I'll now explain
why we have this current drama, okay?
Like why um this current thing is
happening. The reason why the current
thing is happening is because um I was
it all began with the Celeste [__] but
then if you don't know what the Celeste
[__] is, it's stupid. Just like go to my
channel and then click on the responding
to Dan thing for the context, okay? like
you'll get all the comments because I
have a video on it. Um that is like
essentially responding to Dan. Okay.
>> But one of the most important parts is
that all you need to know is that that
is when my beef with Dan essentially
began.
>> Um Dan called me a pedophile. Um because
he got triggered over me like trolling
him in [__] voice chat, which is an
insane response, I guess. Um and then I
DM'd him based off of a friend, a mutual
friend that actually really liked Dan.
Um so they were like, "Please give Dan a
So, I was like, "Okay, fine. I'll give
Dan a chance." So, I DM'd Dan and I was
like, "Hey, do you mind deescalating?
Like, we can fight. I think we can
fight. I think we can fight. However, I
don't appreciate the pedal jacketing.
You can call me a [__] You can call
me whatever, but I don't like the fact
that you're calling me a pedal because
that is not true. I don't believe I'm a
PDF." Okay. Again, from my perspective,
I'm not saying this in dance, okay? I
shouldn't be explaining myself obviously
based off of like unsubstantiated [__]
right? But again,
um, yeah, but then again, right, like
I'm just like, "Oh, well, here it is,
right?" Um,
so then what happened is that then I
leaked my logs of Dan between me and Dan
onto Twitter. And the reason why I did
this is because Dan started deleting the
logs afterwards. He literally started
deleting his own [__] responses to me
instantly afterwards. Um, because I
don't know, maybe he's like, I don't
know why he did that, I guess. But I
honestly do not know, okay? Um, I don't
get what's the point because he'll just
look that if like I just repost the
[__] delete messages. So, I don't
even know why he did it in the first
place. I don't know. He's just kind of
stupid if you're
>> anyhow. All right. So, I posted it and
then
and it just basically showed that he
wasn't he said that as long as you never
talk about me ever, I will never call
you a pedo. That is insane. That's
insane. I'm a person who covers the
space. I'm I'm like a commentator that
covers this space. It's especially if if
you are a player in the space. If you
are a player in this race, I think it's
completely unreasonable if you told me
that um oh yeah, you should never ever
cover me ever. You should avoid me at
all costs. I think that's a [__]
demand. And I think that demand is so
unreasonable. I don't think that's a
real demand. That is not a real demand,
right? Because a real demand would be
trying to compromise and trying to meet
somewhere in the middle and have a
discussion, right? Which is what I was
looking for. But if he gives some demand
like that, I know the message he's
sending. The message he's sending is I
don't want to deescalate. I want to
escalate. Right? I want to continue this
war. So I want to like continue doing
this.
>> Off topic, but is Max still around? Do
you mean Chatteramax or Max Mr. Girl? I
assume you mean ChatterMax. Yeah, Mr.
Girl is still around. Yeah, Matt Max is
federal rape on Twitter. Okay.
>> Right.
>> Um, yeah. MTD says you basically
wouldn't be able to cover any streams
where he's in VC. Yeah. Yeah. I I think
so. Yeah. So, which is unreasonable.
That's crazy because let's just say if
Dan was debating somebody else, right?
If Dan was debating somebody else and it
was really really good content. Really?
I can't commentate on that. like I just
straight up or maybe he means like I
should never criticize him just so so
then my channel in which other people
watch for honest and reliable
information, right? Because people do
watch me to get like drama news about
Destiny, right?
>> This could really impact food
credibility to treat my you know
coverage as like the the best the best
coverage, right? So you're telling me
>> this this could really impact the
perception of food shops integrity. You
know, food shops is known for having
such balanced and fair takes on drama
and this could really impact the
perception of food shop's credibility
if Dan asks not be covered.
>> It gets included. Like I can't cover
anything negative compared to I feel
like it would damage my integrity in the
space. Okay.
>> Right. So reflect poorly.
>> So yeah, complete unreasonable demand.
So obviously that's why I escalated it.
It's very cringe. Um I don't know. He
literally meant don't cover him at all.
I think he just meant don't disparrage
him. If he meant don't disparrage him,
he would have said so. But it's very
clear to me that he's not treating the
conversation seriously. That's it.
Right. Because I wish you were right,
but that's not what he said. Right. I'm
going to read what you said and I'm not
going to like Yeah, because it just
makes no sense. It makes no sense. Like,
would you not try to talk carefully
around that? I don't know. I don't think
the burden of interpretation should be
up to me, right? The burden should be up
to the person who's trying to carefully
word the response. I'm just saying. So,
um, now I guess what happened is that
like I made like a [__] uh driveby
call in into Destiny's room to like uh
essentially uh troll Dan. Yes, I did
troll Dan. It It was just to It was
actually to provoke him and to annoy him
on purpose. Okay. But I don't think it
was anything that was actually But it
was only after because I was banned from
DG Chat by this moderator named Mitch.
And after I got banned from DG Chat um
for like a day only, so I didn't really
give a [__] um for only like a day. Dan
essentially said I heard that Dan said,
"Good job, Mitch. You get a gold star."
So, it was Dan who attacked first again,
right? It was Dan that provoked me again
first, right? And I'm pretty sure Dan
has dropped tons of accusations in DG
chat before that as well. So, and I
ignored all of these. I ignored all of
these because
>> you know what? I'm not going to fall for
it. Okay? I'm not going to give into
hate. I'm not going to give into anger,
whatever. Right? So, um like in that
instance specifically, I'm a very angry
person. Okay? In general. Anyway, the
point is is that he struck first again.
Okay. Like because he has no shame.
Okay. He has no shame. So he struck
first again by by complimenting someone
for banning me and Zip in DG chat. Okay.
Um so then I went into uh the voice chat
and I said and I said uh yeah. No, no,
no. It was while video was playing, but
at the same time it's like yeah, I I
think I have the right of confrontation.
If you're going to say that in DG chat,
right? If you're a specific person and
you say something like that, I think I
have the right of confrontation. Okay. I
I understand you're trying to steal man
Dan here. Okay, but trust me, he is a
very spyful person. Okay, anyway, how
Okay, here's the thing. Okay, he should
get his chance. So, what I did was that
I entered um Destiny voice chat and I
essentially said, "Dan, I heard that I
heard from Zip Zip that you were talking
shit." Okay, and there was no immediate
reply. Um and I was like, "Oh, yeah,
that's what I thought." And then I left,
right? So, that was what I did to piss
him off. Yes, I didn't allow him room to
reply there, but like mainly in my
opinion, like I just wanted to call him
out and then just leave, you know?
That's it. I don't want to overstay my
welcome there. So, uh so that was a
troll. That was genuinely I was trolling
him. Okay, again make it very clear. I
was trolling him. Okay, so because and
by the way, am I not right to troll him
because he complimented someone for
banning me? If he's going to say
something like that, then yeah, of
course I have the right to troll him.
Right. So, um after I trolled him, um he
then spent and and this is the ultimate
event, okay? He then spent the entire
like a large section of the Anything
else podcast on me. He then spent
>> Okay. And
>> a whole segment on me. So, if you guys
just don't remember,
food chop said she hopes Dan's wife and
kids get doxed and swatted, right?
He was saying, "Yeah, I think it's
justified to swat Dan's kids." That's
what she was saying.
And was like rambling like looked
literally drugged up just like slurring
like, "Yo, you know what? I think it's
fair to dogs dance kids and SWAT Dan's
kids." like just mad as hell about the
fact that obviously this community that
they thought they thought thought they'd
found a home in was suddenly referring
to them as a pedophile and that Dan was
leading this charge and it's just like
to at that point once you say that well
I've got my disagreements with Dan
but um you are like you know look look
at the Ethan situation right we're we're
bickering bickering over whether
specific you
content creators did quite enough to uh
mitigate the the risk of certain people
in the community saying things that may
certain, you know, encourage someone at
some point to maybe take action that
might result in harassment. You know,
we're that's the discussion we're having
on the Ethan stuff. Food chops is just
saying, "Yeah, your wife and kid should
be harassed, docked, swatted. People
should go after them." We're there's not
even a question to be had here. There's
not even a [__] question to be had
here. It's like, no, you have done this
insane thing. So, yeah, of course,
obviously, not everything is justified.
Dan can't do whatever he wants at this
point, but you know, Dan's got a lot of
a lot of lenience. I think when you're
taking such hostile,
aggressive,
potentially damaging,
just straight up morally wrong actions
against him, you know?
>> Yeah. Yeah, he gets a little bit of
lenience where it's like, yeah, I mean,
he can he's allowed to hit back
>> on anything else.
Why? Cuz he was probably molding. That's
why. So, yeah. Also, before I begin
covering this, and by the way, this is a
blind covering, okay? So, I have never
reacted to this yet. But, you know, like
I already have like, you know, and
because every single time somebody
covers me, it's always the same. It's
literally always the same thing. So,
it's like like it's boring, okay? It's
really boring, okay? Honestly, it's just
it's not even like it's not even like
interesting, you know? Anyway, um before
I start, um I want to play this clip
from Destiny that was done back then.
And I'm just wondering if you have this
thought about me. If you have this
thought about me and you're questioning
me in this way, right? Because right,
because of the things that I consume
like in terms of like in my private time
without harming anybody IRL, nor would I
ever harm anybody IRL cuz I'm not
actually a PDF. Then you know what? You
know what? Good on you. But did you know
that Destiny was defending the same
thing? Take a look. I don't know. Is
this about to be the hottest take? Am I
about to drop a hot take about
thousand-y old spirits?
Just paint us for people who don't know.
>> Guys, see, Desty says I'm not a
pedophile. Desi says I'm not a
pedophile.
You know what? I am going to drop one. I
don't really give a [__] for life out
here.
>> Obsess over like people that watch
Lollipop. Who the [__] cares? They're
[__] cartoons, bro. Who cares? Why
are you so I think I think I've said
this before and now that we've learned
that projection is real because it
obviously is.
>> I think the most likely place to find
pedophiles are the people that are
online constantly seeing pedophiles in
everything.
>> I think they're the most likely to be
pedophiles where you'll be some guy will
be like, "Wait a second. Did you look at
kid in Disney World when you were at
Disneyland? You must have thought about
[__] them, right?" It's like, "No,
dog. Actually, like I see kids all the
time. I don't think about [__] them
ever." That's it's kind of weird that
you would like people are always saying
that, aren't they? We're always saying
that. I mean, you always have people
saying stuff like that.
>> If you like see a kid, does your mind
instant like you have 15year-olds in
your Discord server? I bet you try to
sex them and send nudes to them and get
nudes from them and you masturbate over
every [__] thing they say in chat,
don't you? All the time. Like, no, not
actually, dog. No, that you know that,
man. It sounds like you got some
firsthand experience. Like, I don't
know, man. Sometimes there are people
there are people that go like really
overboard sometimes when they like point
out like that guy's a [__] pedophile.
It's like how do you know he's a
pedophile? He drives right next to a
[__] grade school on his way to work
every morning and there are other routes
that you can take. It's like, okay, is
that that's it for you? That's the line.
That's how you know like Jesus. I don't
know, man. Because I've like now I've
seen so many now I've seen so many cases
of projection before where people will
like project like this insane [__] I
hate that this meme is real. I hate that
this is real, but how many guys do this
[__] where it's like I respect women's
rights, blah blah blah, and then they
get me too and it's like so John the uh
SJW understander, the guy that logged
in, you know, two weeks ago tried to
[__] log into my vagina when I stayed
over his house and I told him no like 27
times. you know, like it feels like
there's some feels like the projection
might be real, you know? I don't know. I
just I'm just saying some people online
have this like really unhealthy
obsession with like hunters talking
about pedophiles where
they'll just be like,
>> "Wow, they just scream about this. This
guy's very damn dude woke, isn't he?
Very ascended.
>> He really sees through the matrix." I'm
sick of listening to his home in other
people
>> comeling tones, though, frankly. Okay,
so I'm going to skip the end of that
clip because I find the guy [__]
sickening to listen to
>> allegations. There's also another clip
out there. There's also another clip out
there of Dan saying that people
shouldn't throw around PDF allegations
loosely without much evidence, right?
Like, oh, people shouldn't be throwing
around these things loosely. Bro, you're
the one doing it. By the way, he was
saying that to defend Stephen. Okay,
which I mean, fair enough. I agree with
that. Okay, however, you're a hypocrite.
Okay, like you're you're contradicting
yourself. All right, which is why like
in my opinion, it's like you like you
are so you're so loweffort drama. Like
you are actually like a loweffort drama
monger like unironically like you are
not putting in any effort into this
which is why like
>> felt your surroundings.
>> Oh thank you sleepy but like um again
it's just like dude like why would you
ever say [__] like this when I can
literally dig up so many clips of you
saying stupid [__] all the time. Like
why would you ever do this? It's like
it's like Ethan Klein and Pedal Troll.
Like you just don't learn. And you're
also allied with Ethan Klein which is
ironically the funniest part right
again. It's the Ethan Klein pedal troll
thing like over and over again. Right.
And then not only that, like um I guess
Dan also like calls people pedal all the
time as a joke. Um but here's the thing.
I don't think that's acceptable. I don't
think that's okay. Okay? Like there are
some things that you can joke about, but
if it's regular in the space, I think
that's fine, but I think you have to be
kind of careful. Like for example, I I
would I don't allow people to joke about
other people being a PDF um uh in my
Genjat in my server, right? Um like I
would never I would never ever like do
something like that, you know? Like I I
I don't support it. We're very edgy.
We're extremely edgy in the Gat like in
in my server. We're extremely edgy, but
we don't do that. We do not do that.
Okay. Um, so yeah, I don't know. This is
like very perplexing to me, I guess.
Oh, yeah. People are saying um people
are saying like, "Oh my god, are you
surprised that you got banned from uh DJ
Perms or something?" I'm not
complaining. I'm not surprised either. I
accept stoism. Okay. I think that Yeah,
obviously if I annoy Steven, obviously
he's going to take away my ter perms.
Okay. Yeah, I'm okay with that. Like I'm
not going to blame anybody for like
taking away perms for a completely
understandable reason. Okay. Anyway,
um so I guess like I don't know. It's
just it's just so cringe. Um I don't
know. Like this is also very low effort
like once again, right? Um oops. Sorry,
that was Babylon 5. I [__] love that
5. Londo. Sorry.
Um right. Okay, let me think about what
else is there. I'm sure like they're
going to make a lot of bad faith
characterizations of me. Um
so it's just
>> so be bad faith that would make food
look bad.
>> I don't know. That's it. Anyway,
>> oh yeah, I want to clarify that both one
time she went on a
>> it's Dan's fault. Okay, it's like both
times Dan full context of this
>> ch debate panel and was like, "Yeah, I'm
a small P pedophile. I I pedophile small
P."
>> Yeah, you really need to be bad faith to
make that look bad. That requires you
really um
you know misconstring
the situation. Okay, so whatever Dan
says, that's the full context. Okay,
make sure to um correct him. All right,
>> pull that pull that up. They're like
pulling up in a browser source. That's
unique.
>> Yeah, I don't know why he's doing like
that. He's [__]
>> All right, content time. Oh, one last
thing. Okay, Mabest, cut this part out.
Okay. Um, let's promo. Okay. All right.
I'll see you guys in a tiny tiny bit.
I'm asking for
>> awful
>> promotion script reads
>> the money.
Do the segment. Okay. So, again, all
right. I went in for 5 seconds to troll
Dan. 5 seconds to get Dan riled up. What
does he do? spends an entire segment on
anything else pedal jacketing me, okay?
Or PDF jacketing me. All right, just
want to be very clear on what the
escalation is. Okay, so again, 5 seconds
of me trolling Dan
and he escalates it to an entire segment
PDF jacket me.
And by the way, I'm not even talking
about like I'm not even talking about
like Dan participating in JSTO's Discord
server
to to complain about me. If you guys
don't know, Dan apparently is like
active again in JTO's Discord server
because they hate me. So, he is finding
like camaraderie camaraderie with his
best friends anti-fans
for their hatred on me. What a great
friend, am I right? What a fantastic
friend. Um, but yeah, it's really
[__] weird, I guess. It's like, why
would you do that? Anyway, I don't
There's like this fake Discord
notification they've got here that says
leave voice. Someone you blocked has
joined. If you leave, they will still be
blocked.
Uh,
it says food shops is here as a warning
saying children should immediately be
removed from the from the voice chat or
some [__] like that. Children should
immediately be removed from the
vicinity. Sorry, it's tiny and blurry. I
can't quite see. Which is awesome.
That's awesome. Um, and by the way, yes,
there is evidence for all of this. Okay.
Um, just go to my first video on Dan.
Um, and then you'll see the receipts.
All right. I'm just saying. Okay.
Anyway, was a troll talking about his
kids and wiping dogs? No, that's a
that's before that. The kids and wiping
dogs part. I thought it was fair only
because
>> a martini shaken not stirred.
>> I know it's a bit off topic, but I hyped
your video recently and was curious how
that affects it and if and how it shows
you.
>> Yo, Big Gabriel, thank you so much for
$5. Um, how that affects and if and how
it shows you. Um, what do you mean by
that?
>> I I I don't know what that means. I'm
sorry. Um,
>> confusing. Oh, by the way, thank you.
Thank you once again for the 20. I
appreciate that. Um, also another thing,
yes, I did talk like unhinged [__] about
Ant. Okay, I did and I will own that.
The reason why I own that is because I
gave him the option of deescalation. He
rejected that option and instead he
escalated it, right? His his offer was
completely non-serious and a complete
escalation in my opinion. So, in my
opinion, yeah, I have no reason not to
go full nuclear, right? If he's going to
go full nuclear and call me a PDF, which
is like one of the worst things you can
do online to another content creator,
then yeah, in my opinion, I I don't have
to hold anything back. Okay? Like I
think at every single every single step
here I've been completely reasonable.
Okay. So obviously I'm going to say the
most unhinged [__] because he's also
like going full unhinged. And he also
describes to me that he's going to be
full unhinged. So it's like yeah of
course right like duh. Yeah. Anyway.
>> Um yeah
that was that was me last night when I
was in voice with Steve and someone
joined at the same time and uh
>> he's been in there more after his little
crash out.
Oh yeah. So I guess okay. So this is
Dan. So this is Dan in Jesus.
>> This person I know nothing about this
guy.
>> Okay. Very
rude misgendering in that super chat. I
would like to say
terrible stuff. Very bad.
However, yes. Uh this is food food
shops. Okay.
First
showed up streaming as you know. Always
wanting to be a Destiny orbiter. Was
always a big Destiny fan. always very
clearly wanted to be a Destiny Orbiter.
Um,
but only got their chance because they
were, you know, known as kind of like a
pedophile, an annoying pedophile for a
long time, which is like one of the
worst things you can possibly be known
as, as an annoying pedophile.
They they only got their chance
eventually once everyone else had left.
when Destiny needed someone to be
arguing on his side completely
uncritically on the pixie and all the
other drama surrounding it.
So now she's been brought in to the DG
fold
and has immediately started burning all
bridges there, antagonizing Dan by
saying his wife and kids deserve to be
doxed and now they're all bringing up
her pedophile dramas again.
So So that's the TLDDR. Hopefully that
roughly summarizes it to you.
and more so
>> trans Asian pedophile.
>> Like what is he doing? Seriously, maybe
like I was asking has he been in there?
Oh, I I don't know. I have child.
>> I think I have birdies who are willing
to tell me. Okay. Anyway,
>> my perfect online reputation, I would 10
times be more concerned. Um at least
return by the way. Okay, for people who
are saying, "Okay, sorry life. Okay, I
appreciate you. Okay, I appreciate you
hearing me out. However, I will say that
like you can 100% like if you call
somebody a PDF online and I've already
been doxed, someone can definitely swap
me. I'm just saying someone can
definitely swap me because if they feel
strongly enough about Dan calling me a
PDF, 100%. It's like I I don't even need
to go into that. So obviously if I like
if I say crazy unhinged [__] about Dan,
about Dan, his kids, and his wife, it's
fair game. You bring me to the surface
risk me to dangerous [__]
>> It's fair game. Okay, you did it first.
All right.
>> Oh god. I just don't know what to say.
>> But calling food trucks a pedophile is a
totally reasonable interpretation of the
evidence.
Like it it actually does not require bad
faith or malice or anything to think
that food shops is a pedophile at all.
>> It's like ah you know just
>> like have you seen how predator hunters
hunt like like PDS or or people that
they think are PDS? Not only do they
like it's completely [__] It's crazy.
It's insane.
>> I'm good fam. I just I don't even want
to go after next to them, you know?
That's it. It's the [__]
>> I I I blame this I blame this on the
entire generation of um uh grow growing
up watching Chris Hansen. Okay, I blame
Chris Hansen. All right, I blame Chris
Hansen for raising an entire like two
generations worth of like unhinged
people like Dan. Okay,
>> alert.
>> And by the way, okay, hold on.
>> For anybody wondering why so much PDF
allegations are like coming out like
during this century, it's because of
Chris Hansen. Okay, Chris Hansen ruined
a lie. Yeah, he affected the entire
culture in my opinion. But yeah,
>> I want to throw I want to throw
something out here real quick. Steve,
one second again. Um,
>> look at him. He's waiting.
>> Okay. Yeah, sorry. Last thing. Okay. Um,
I don't know Zip super well. Okay. But I
have no issue with him. However, this is
a strategy that the unnamed one uh from
the previous meme is continually trying
to do because they're desperately trying
to latch on to someone else. Be like,
"Ah, Destiny is or sorry, Dan is against
this person and this person."
>> No, I have no problem with Zipo. Oh, no.
I said earlier
>> the unnamed one. Like remember, you know
how I said that people were scared of me
and how people like didn't want to
mention me and [__] And I don't know.
Sometimes I'm like thinking to myself,
am I like delusional? Like am I thinking
that like am I thinking that people are
just like am I thinking that I have a
bigger like presence than I actually do
or something? But then Dan is here on
anything else calling me the unnamed one
which makes me think that all of my
prior assumptions are are are validated.
Why Pisco avoids saying my name. Why um
why Hutch these days like he tries to
avoid and stuff like that. I mean if I
have that kind of reputation behind the
scenes and yeah like I'm not surprised,
right? The unnamed one. That's crazy.
>> That's a little too.
>> And they're very sneakily trying to
attach that uh to Next. It's going to be
Radiant who, you know, can redeem
himself. You know, he's been a very good
sport. I'll say that. So don't delusion.
Even though I know there's like a
>> like thinking they've got some like
debate skill or like they're
particularly cutting or like
I I truly don't know what is going on in
this person's [__] head to think that
there's like any weight behind the
threats or like attacks that are being
that are being thrown around.
By the way, this is a little kind of
weird as well is because like I I don't
think any of these orbiters require
Dan's validation to be approved in DG.
This is a little bit because Dan is like
kind of taking the reigns of being like
the leader of DG or something.
>> Kind of weird, but do what you want,
right? But like it's like, oh, like
these people can redeem themselves. They
can they can redeem themselves in my
eyes. They can do it. Okay, just try a
little harder and they're able to redeem
them. Like, can you stop being like are
you okay? Play Jesus.
>> Yeah. like like this is like a power
trip fantasy, you know?
>> No, there's some animosity and there's
still some stuff to learn, but still
he's been a good sport about it. He
hasn't turned and gone. Okay, so that
said, um
>> he's like drunk on.
>> You're all in this by yourself. You
ain't got no friends. Okay, I was trying
to not as unhinged cuz mutin is just
there for the money. That's why
dad and Destiny have such ego wrapped up
in it. Mutton is just there for the
money. Mutton ain't got [__] else going
on.
>> Drag someone else down with you. Okay,
that's you. Sorry. Go ahead, Steve.
>> I like Well, hold on, Steve. I like
Radiant. I think they're a lot of fun.
They're funny and they haven't caused,
you know, any crazy issues. They are
good.
>> They are They are [__]
>> bro. The unnamed one is still kind of
wild. Okay, I can't get over that part.
The unnamed one. I'm taking it. Okay,
>> that sounds cool as [__] Sometimes the
best names are given by your
>> The Ubi key thing was something for the
[__] ages. Like,
>> [__] sure, but it's funny. Uh, Zip
Zip is fine. I just think he joins
sometimes and talks too much. But the
same can be said for me, I guess.
>> Well, the same can be said for many many
many people. It is a skill that you
learn to know when to shut the [__] up.
And I think I've honed the skill pretty
pretty easily. Uh example, yesterday I
just [__] left when he was watching
the Desh debate because I knew that he
needed to farm content a little bit. So,
I [__] off. Um
food shops.
>> I just I'm looking for
>> You just mentioned the name. I'll say I
don't like them because they come and
channel and they [__] they [__]
scream like a [__] Okay, she's got to
stop doing that when I'm in there. And
thankfully she has she hasn't joined
when I've been in there recently. So
that's nice.
>> Yeah, that's looking for you.
>> By the way, I just want to say that has
happened once. Okay. Um I I don't know
why Mr.
>> It only takes once to be annoying as
[__] [__]
>> As if it happens all the time. I'm not
joking. It has
>> figure it out. Figure figure it out
already. You got given access to a live
channel. Don't be [__] with it.
Like, you know, I hate the DG Orbiter
games as much as anyone else, but holy
[__]
Like,
you're you're like an annoying prick.
Just just joining and screaming. Yeah,
it's annoying as [__] Like, at this
point, now has happened twice. Now, it
has happened twice. And honestly, I
would do it again. Okay. If I still had
perms if I had
>> This is the exact problem. This is the
exact problem.
>> Okay. But the thing is is that like
>> I only did it once at this point of of
their recording. Once. Once. And and
like he's talking about as if I do it.
Okay. Okay. [__] I gotta find this this
Listen, someone sent me like a [__]
companion.
>> I don't know why you keep saying she.
There you go. We're using her pronouns.
You [__] retards. I No one here is
misgendering food shops. That's not
happening.
>> I I didn't say he one time.
>> We're not doing that.
>> Uh
>> even if we don't like them, we're still
going to use their pronouns. You [__]
retards.
>> We're uh [__] I sent an imager thing.
I'm looking for it meow. Um hold on.
Standby. Who would I have sent this to?
>> Someone.
>> Hold on.
>> I said M, not him. M as in them. You
[__] absolute [__] Truly, this is
the dankkest dungeon.
>> Msaki, thank you so much for the 10
gifted subs on kick. Remember, every
dollar donated to me is another dollar
donated towards hating Dan justifiably,
okay? Dan is like one of the most
justifiably hated people, okay? In my
opinion. All right, remember, okay, I'm
always on the side of light, okay? I'm
always on the side of goodness, okay?
And we will crush the evil. We will
crush the darkness. Okay, thank you so
much for the 10 gifted subs. Okay, I
appreciate that. Oh god,
>> you're literally [__] [__]
>> Hold on. I'm thinking. I'm thinking. I'm
thinking I'm thinking.
>> You can listen to how I say this all the
time. I say M. I say, "Oh, I don't
really like them." Um, I don't really
like um not um
>> Okay, skipping that bit.
>> Jesus Christ.
>> Like name X name.
>> Probably not an argument. Holy [__] Y
name.
>> Like I see that all the time. The humor
is just kind of like that. It's a
[__] boy club. Okay. Like what do you
want to say?
>> If that is Yeah. That's just basically
this. And I was like
>> it happens all the time.
>> [__] I have this somewhere in my
>> I don't give a [__] It's just it's just
kind of weird. There are [__] nobody.
Who gives a [__] Let's Let's just
continue
Mr. Mutton. I think he's kind of a
loser. I don't really think much of him.
He's he's kind of like a loser. I see
him as like a playing wrong Destiny
playing wrong. Destiny fanboy,
but not intelligent enough to be
particularly involved or thoughtful
about any of the politics stuff.
>> So, Mutin, it seems like Mutin is trying
to just move on. Okay. All right. Good
for you, Mutin. Okay. And and here's the
thing. I will give Mutin credit here,
okay? Like trying to move on from a
subject that seems like a totally
[__] subject that seems to like just
be Dan. Like I I I'm like I fully
believe here that Dan is trying to
compete for the number one like living
rentree in their head position with
Counterpoints in terms of me. Okay. Just
like how counterpoints lives has me
living rentree in their head. I think
that Dan is trying to compete for that
position. Okay. I think that's what's
going on because nobody wants to hear
him talk about Hassan and Fu Chops.
Okay, it's cringe. false emerging
government. But the opinion for example
is illegal.
>> By the way, I don't think that's
illegal. Steve was on to something here.
He didn't follow through. Uh like if you
if you have a reasonable belief that um
someone's kid like in reasonable is like
doing a lot of heavy lifting here. But
if if for instance if Mr. Mutton was
like, hey, you know, my
>> awkward
>> Peach is really sick and it's cuz I keep
[__] on the floor. It would be even
if I was like, you know, maybe someone
should call protective services. It
seems like Peach is getting abused. I
saw a video of her getting slammed into
the wall. Like that's not illegal for me
to do that. It's [__] up because I
think everyone knows that's not like the
real deal, right? They're not actually
slamming each other into the wall out of
anything. But
>> correct.
>> We don't care about the H3 debate stuff.
>> This is all stuff that
>> Let's really get to the Let's get to the
key points here.
>> Sitting there and waiting for this [__]
to happen is not fun.
Okay, here we go. So,
>> this uh absolute [__] creatures
VC with Dan and Mr. Moot confronts them.
So, let's see how it goes. You want
people to be [__] Let me see if I can
find the motation. Um, that that is a
predominant structural concern.
>> Zip told me that you guys were talking
[__] calling me a pedto. What's going
on here?
>> Yes, let's go.
>> Okay, you have clips out there saying
that you're a pedophile. What What are
we supposed to think? I asked you in DG
chat once. I asked you in DG chat. I
said, "Are you a pedophile?" And you
typed dot dot dot and that was it. So,
why not just answer? Okay, why not just
answer the question then? I don't know
who you are, so I'm obviously trying to
learn if you're
>> Also, also, can I just say it's so
[__] weird. Like, it's so [__]
weird that
What did I just get shot by? Hello? Was
that a player? Anyway, whatever. It
doesn't matter. Like again, it's just
kind of weird that like is this a
question you should ask people? Like can
you just imagine me going up to someone
I barely know and going like I think
you're a pedophile. Can you please
confirm to me whether or not you're a
ped
>> Why do I owe you this answer?
>> What? Hello [__] pedophile or not?
I've asked this a few times and you
never with a random stranger. There's no
reason to believe they might be a
pedophile. So why would you randomly go
up to them and ask?
>> Now the issue you've got is there is
actually quite a lot of reason to
believe that you are a pedophile. So if
someone encounters you and asks you
about that, you should probably be ready
to answer.
>> Like this is such a weird like such a
weird thing to demand of someone. It's
just so weird. Like what the [__] weird
feels weird is calling yourself a
pedophile.
>> Uh I mean you can continue to call me
pedal if you want. Like I don't like
what do you want?
>> I need to call I probably shouldn't have
said this but like I was in the middle
of some [__] Oh yo. Hey yo. What's up?
you you okay I you need to learn that
there are substantive I don't want to
say like legitimate but at least
substantive claims that you might be
about based on like the what you've said
before in the past when people ask you
in DG chat they're not asking that
they're not asking like as a joke they
don't want you to joke you should
probably go on like a campaign where you
where you just say no every single time
like it's not it's when people when
people like when people see those those
statements in G chat they're you're just
kind of feeling the fire where people
are that's what people expect from you
Now people like some Sure. Okay. Yeah,
sure. I understand what you're talking
about, but the problem here is
>> So guys, now is a great time. I'm g I'm
gonna shill quickly. Okay.
>> 360 people here, 17 likes on the stream.
Some of those 350 or so people and
please move the cursor thumbs up,
clicking or pressing the thumbs up on
the mobile device. That be appreciated.
If you want to take your support one
step further,
uh you can do directly through streams
link pin chat message. You can also buy
a membership to channel. Gift a
membership the channel. Gift a whole
bunch of memberships around without the
chat. Buy a super chat to your heart or
message or read out or buy a super
sticker. Wish your YouTube image or gift
highlight in chat. I'll subscribe it to
you. You can go to discord.gg/creamman.
Twitter.com.
Did I say all of them there? I can't
remember. Thank you for the membership.
Thank you. 67 67
Okay.
6,700 years. Take these chains off and
say that again. Hey men and the men of
pigs. Hey men and the men of pigs.
Crying crying crying crying.
>> Is that um number one I have gone on a
campaign saying no and no and no and no
before. Okay. It's just never worked.
Like there's something like because
because if I say no, they'll think I'm
lying. Right. You're getting more more
attention now. Now that you're in DG,
you're becoming a more popular orbiter.
you're becoming a more pro prominent
figure now that and before in the past
you were public no bullshitter now
you're getting actual people and now
ever since you've been in DG you you
kind of just [__] you kind of just
play around the fact you kind of
>> this 90-year-old diner still makes coke
the oldfashioned way
>> like beat around the bush you're like oh
whatever I don't give a [__] if comment
you should give a [__] like Mr. Putin
when he says when when Mr. is asking
whether or not you should be a
pedophile. The reason he's asking is
because he wants to know whether or not
he should uh he should like correspond
with you where he should affiliate with
you. That's like the whole reason he's
asking because he doesn't want to
affiliate with somebody who he thinks is
my
>> hold on you got to let me respond. If if
he doesn't want to affiliate, he doesn't
have to affiliate. Okay, that's number
one. Number two, um you said hold on,
let me respond. Number two, um you said,
"Yeah, why don't you just respond no in
DG chat?" Okay, typically people who are
asking that question in DG chat
specifically, they're not actually
looking for a genuine answer or
>> I know they're not looking for No, let
me answer. I have to explain myself.
every single time.
>> Okay, go go go ahead. I'm sorry.
>> I have to be okay. Like, do you notice
how it's kind of weird that you're like,
"Okay, well, you have to be strong
against the people who are trying to
call me a PDF." Like a bunch of people
calling me a PDF. I have to be strong
against that, bro. Like, you're telling
me to fight a battle that is essentially
like like so difficult to fight, it's
just impossible, right? You're telling
me to keep on like um refuting my
allegation again again? Like, I would
never ask Steven to refute his CP
allegation again.
>> I need to Google how to make Coke the
oldfashioned way. We'll all be finding
out pretty soon. And trust me, we'll all
be finding out pretty soon.
>> Debunks his own allegations. Even if he
spends time debunking that, the people
who are going to ask in the future, even
5 years from now, are 100% like are 100%
still going to be putting that on him,
but he shouldn't feel the obligation to
respond like every single time, right?
And this is the part that I feel like
people don't understand about content
creators is that like even if you
disprove the allegations a single time,
it's going to come back again and again.
The reason why I said this was like
lolliggate version 4 is because it
literally is like the fourth [__]
time that I have to like respond to the
same thing over and over again, right?
And obviously like I'm I'm a lot more
calmer this time, but it's just like it
just makes no sense, you know? That's
it.
>> Okay, there's two things. One, when you
when So those people who are they're
obviously trying to bait you, but when
you say that, when you when you give
into that, you're giving them exactly
what they want. You're giving them more
ammunition for them to call you a
pedophile. You are in DG chat, you want
to build a bigger brand in DG chat. You
probably you probably should want to
build a bigger audience in DG chat. And
>> no way. There's no way people online are
trying to find reasons to call other
people pedophiles. No way.
>> You need to knock you not giving you
need to at least say no every single
time. You can't just say, "Oh, like
whatever."
>> Are you okay? Okay. Okay. Okay. Are you
I mean, maybe like I I think you have a
point there as in like, "Okay, maybe you
should put that out there." But I'm just
saying like I I'm pretty sure I have
addressed this like multiple times on my
channel even now, right? And I don't
think anybody is like that aren't
watching people, that's fine. That's
fine. That's fine. No, no, no. I
understand. Okay. But here's the thing.
Do you believe in tipper tat? Like do
you believe in like trying to cater to
people and whatever like that? Like what
is your opinion on that? Cuz if you if
you believe this is this is your
favorite thing would be like, "Oh, hey,
this person calls me a pedophile. I'm
going to call pedophile back." You're
you're saying these people are calling
you a pedophile and then you're saying,
"Oh, it's a meme. [__] yeah, I am." And
then like I don't give a [__] I like I
watch whatever.
>> Wait, hold on. When was the last time I
said [__] yeah, I was. When did I say
that?
>> Well, no. In TG chat, I remember at
least within the last week you said that
you look at Lolli. Like I I know you
have.
>> Wait, is that a confession to me saying
that I'm a PDF? Hello.
>> It's not It's not in DG. They're going
to call you a pedophile just for
>> Okay, so why do you frame it like that?
Because the problem that I have here is
that you're trying to frame me like oh
why' you like if I was going into GG
chat and I was genuinely going like hey
guys I'm a PDF or whatever then yeah
like I probably deserve to be like that
because it's like why would you blame me
for something like that right but the
problem is that people are asking
>> the way you work around it when I'm
sorry when I don't really mean to say
that you're exasper you're like saying
you're like celebrating that you're
you're a PF you're not
>> I don't like that framing like that's
just straight you're g you're creating a
you're creating this like kind of like
view where everybody every time that
they look at you and every time that
everybody asks they well now Oh, this
person didn't uh like they didn't object
to being a pedophile. Oh, that must mean
that they are if if they aren't if like
what Mr. Mutton says is when you were in
chat with him and when he's asking you
give them dot dots, you give them blank
answers, you just ignore them, you do
that, and then in chat you say that oh
yeah, I have like a lolly, you do all
that, you're going to get you're going
to get these [__] responses where
people are going to say that you're a
pedophile and people aren't
>> I think I think that if people ask me in
public whether or not I'm a PDF, that's
ridiculous. That's a ridiculous standard
to set in my opinion. Like if you ask if
I ask
>> you have to do that.
>> Is this a conversation? Hello. Is this
mic working? Like I'm trying to have a
conversation here. Okay. Like again in
my opinion I'm trying to provide my
justification. Okay.
>> Therefore only gates. How does it get to
that point?
>> Um
what food shop says because of the
Stryand effect. What food shops thinks
the Stryand effect is is when you keep
mentioning something over and over again
and people keep talking about it. Okay.
That's what food shops has described as
a Striand effect. So that's how it keeps
happening is because um either food
shops talks about it or someone else
talks about it and food shops always
responds and and starts fighting about
it and then more people talk about it
and then there's more clips of food shop
saying stuff about it and it keeps
getting worse.
If in public, if in public, why is it
why is it considered like weird when you
are the one who is in the wrong for
giving a answer or or not giving an
answer when the other person is the one
who is asking or trying to imply that
you are a PDF, right? Like like I would
never go up to a stranger or go up to
someone I don't know and go like, "Hey,
I think that you're a PDF. Can you prove
that you're not a PDF or something?"
Like what the [__] am I supposed to like
like and the other person says no? Like
I don't think the obligation should be
on them to say no because in my opinion
if you say that to me in public that's a
bad faith question because if you
actually did care about like whether or
not I was actually a PDF or not you
would DM me in private and people have
DM me in private before and I've
explained whether or not like like my
entire history right if Mr. Putin really
cared. He would DM me in private. But
let's just be honest. The reason why he
did that in DG chat is because he
doesn't give a [__] right?
>> You're that's 100% true. But that that's
that doesn't make that you have to say
right now you're looking at yourself as
though you're a person on the street.
You're not a person on the street.
You're a celebrity. Like you're a micro
celebrity, but you're a public figure.
So when people go up to you and they ask
you, hey, are you a pedophile? And then
you work around it as a public figure.
That means that now people are going to
look at what your statement or not
statement is to that and now that's how
they're going to perceive you.
>> Uh okay. I I mean we might just have to
agree to disagree because like in my
opinion um I okay
what what do you propose from now on to
do? Okay. What would your be actionable
plan in your opinion? Okay
>> when you are in DGG and when everybody
anybody asking because those people
definitely don't watch your content.
They definitely don't watch the where
you deny being
>> I No, hold on. Hold on. Hold on. I will
say
>> they don't they don't 100%.
>> Hold on. I'm not talking about that. I'm
not talking about that. I'm not talking
about that. Do not watch. Okay. I don't
like how you're cutting me off every
single time. I'm about to say something
like Okay.
What in my opinion, what do I have to
do? Do do you think that every single
time somebody brings that up to me, I
have to say no to every single one of
them? Every single time?
>> No, not every single one of them. But if
you if there's if there's somebody if
you're in chat and you're responding to
somebody in chat about that, you have to
say no. That's like kind of the
obligation that you have at that point.
So like let's say you're in DG chat. If
you're in DG chat, you're chatting and
chatting and chatting and somebody asks
you that, you could do one of two
things. You can either ignore them or if
you respond, you have to say no.
>> Hold on. No, no, no. I don't I don't
like this representation because you
don't have the I don't like this
representation. I don't No, no, no. I
don't like what you're saying. The
reason why I don't like what you're
saying is because you're assuming that
everybody in there is is talking in good
faith. You're assuming that everybody in
there is not.
>> It's not being assumed at all. Absolute
[__] We're gonna skip through some of
this.
>> Like if
>> I think the only interesting part from
this little conversation really is that
this person points out that DJ has had a
50% drop off in in chatters over the
last year since all the drama shit's
happened.
>> You can just keep going.
>> Okay, hold on. There's like multiple
reasons why I disagree with you there,
but like
things I'm talking about, right?
>> Okay, that's fine.
for I see it. No, no, no, no. If I get
>> Do you want to stagnate here at like
what 100 viewers or whatever for like
forever? No. You want to build more
viewers? You want to build build a
bigger audience?
>> Yeah, but why would audience why would I
even want like that's already the
problem with what you're saying is that
there's a growth cap as well. Like if I
only try to appeal to DG, why why don't
I appeal to why don't I appeal to
communities outside of DG as well?
Because that's what I've been trying to
do this entire time because I know that
if I cover um JTOK every single day, I
know that a bunch of DGers will just
flock and watch my streams. But the
reason why I don't do that every single
day is because um there's this trap that
content creators constantly fall into
where they pigeon hole themselves into
covering one type of content and they're
trapped within this one community,
right? Why would I try to make my way
towards pulling myself even more when
I'm actually trying to get out of the
algorithm in terms of that thing, right?
It makes no sense to me. That's
counterintuitive to my goals.
>> Your audience in multiple different ways
and you can you want to build your
audience and your stream in the way that
you want to build your streaming.
>> There's a big non-destiny audience for
food chops. I'm I'm sure I'm sure
>> and how and how you perceive it. But
there's a what I'm trying to say is that
if when you're building your audience in
Destiny stream, when you're there, you
should deny being a pedophile because
you're not one and people when people
ask you there, you're saying, "Oh, well,
they're trolling. They're bad faith. It
doesn't matter. Who gives a fuck?" Like,
but it does matter because now you're
you're you're capping what you can do in
that in that space. You're you are
capping food shops as bad as talent as
Ch, right? Food shops can do what Chad
did. Move from Destiny community to
building online, I think. Right.
>> Just by not doing it by just by not
denying
Yeah, I'm okay with that. I'm okay with
that. Like my my ultimate goal again,
why why would you question
>> Hold on.
>> How much do you know about content
creation and algorithms and stuff like
that? Like I'm I'm sorry. I am asking
you to I am asking to pull you I I am
actually asking you to pull out your
credentials at this point because now
you're they're having an issue with my
content creation strategy. So it's like
if you have a issue with my content
creation strategy, yeah, I'm going to
ask you to pull out like whatever
experience you've had prior like in
terms of content creation because
otherwise like why would they take you
seriously, right?
>> No, I'm not I'm not I'm not I'm not
talking about your content. I'm just
saying that when you
>> No, but you are you really want me to
You really want to push in that
direction. So, yeah, we have to talk
about it.
>> Wrong wrong. You're wrong. I I You can
build your stream by saying the public
perception of how you want your if you
how you want to grow is you're capping
yourself not just in Destiny's stream,
which is where that's the most immediate
effect. You're capping yourself
everywhere by not denying it. All right.
Destiny doesn't need to do this anymore
because he's already built his stream.
He already built his audience. He
probably can't grow any further than
>> She's so much worse than Hutch. Yeah,
but that's not saying anything because
like yeah, Hutch is like meant to be a
sensibly mostly normal person and Food
Chops is like a legitimately
on seriously unstable
deranged
borderline pedophile. Like
yeah, I would I would hope Archers
is slightly better than this
>> than he is based on.
>> Yeah, I mean good for Destiny. Okay.
Yeah, good for Destiny. for him here.
>> I mean, I just don't again I don't want
to spend all my time like trying to
prove myself to a chat that already
hates me and also is not worth your
time. It just makes no sense.
>> Okay.
>> But you're doing this thing like
>> I don't know. I don't know how to
convince you. It's just like like what
am I supposed to say here? I don't want
to deny every single every single
instance of DG chat. I don't want to
have to deny every single instance every
single time, which is not what I'm
saying. But then I go back and I look at
your logs. It's not you denying every
single time. It's it's you playing into
it or meaning about it. Like there's
there's definitely a difference between
the two where you can't find some middle
ground where you just deny it. Most all
like every time that you're going to
acknowledge it, you deny it. You you're
going to have to
>> Yeah. Because I don't care all that much
about what DG chat thinks of me.
>> Yeah. This caller is giving very basic
inarguable advice of just do not allow
there to be ambiguity about whether
you're a pedophile or not. You will have
an easier life if it is unambiguous as
possible as to whether you're a
pedophile or not. Make it clear.
Very very simple advice. I think most
people intuitively understand this. Food
shops. Uh not so much.
>> But then then you're going to have to
you're going to have to struggle with
with these people.
>> I only I only care
>> if I think
>> let's uh try I want to get back into
>> I don't disagree with that.
>> No, that's not right. And number three,
I want to be that kind of content
creator where it doesn't matter how I'm
looked upon by other communities. I just
want to defend what I think is right.
Right. And and you know what? If that's
not to your liking, if you think it's a
bad content strategy, good for you.
>> That's exactly what's happening, right?
That's exactly what's happening.
>> Your opinion, right? But but you're
you're you're haven't even asked me how
much importance I place on getting the
goodwill of DG chat before assuming
automatically that that is like one of
my primary goals. And it's like, no,
it's not. It's a side benefit if I take
it. It's a side benefit if I take it.
>> Building your building your audience
there is a good idea. You there's
there's a sizable audience there for you
to pick up where they basically agree
with literally everything you agree
with. They like they like the same
things you like. They they like it when
you shoot on digital. They like they
like those things. Your streams could be
very popular DG, but you're capping
yourself there because you choose to
basically meme around the fact
>> you realize you realize I'm also capping
myself.
>> You are one. So that mean that's just
how it is.
>> Hold on. You've realized I'm also
capping myself by [__] on the
anti-fans, right?
>> I'll explain. When I am saying no, no,
no. You said that you agree with it. I'm
assuming that you're
>> because if we because we only assume
>> because because if we only assume what
is a good choice based on maximizing
viewership and stuff, there could be
other things I could be doing, right? if
I was truly shameless. But I choose not
to do that.
>> I'm not saying you're being shameless.
When I'm saying that you can grow in a
des
>> Okay, that's it. That looks like the end
of that vod. I think
>> you made me sad. You made me sad. Okay.
Oh, just get a bit so it gets back into
he somewhere around here.
Booty is too black.
>> Yeah. Yeah. We We'll watch D versus All
right. We'll get to it eventually, guys.
We'll get to
>> He thinks there's no hope and there's
nothing she can do. Yes. There's nothing
I can do. Okay. I'm telling you right
now. All right. After the fourth, you
know, after the first time trying to
disprove some [__] Um, and I'm not
mean. No, I understand. Okay. You guys
can disagree with me. Okay. You guys are
free to disagree me. Okay. All right. I
understand. I also understand your
point. Okay. I think I can steal man
your points pretty well. Okay. It's not
like Yeah. It's not like I don't like
disagree with you need to you got to
take a chill pill. Okay. My bad for not
being chill, I guess. But like in my
opinion, it's Hey women and the women
are Diddy Bloods. Skull. Thank you for
the contribution, Kirby. Thank you for
the valuable contribution.
>> Somebody if somebody is like confronting
me on how I handle allegations regarding
like me being a PDF, like you have to
understand why I'm not chill, right?
It's a very tense topic. It's a very
spicy topic. It's a It's a topic that
everybody is tense on. So, yeah. Forgive
me, I guess, for not like being calm, I
guess, during my own [__] allegation.
Okay. All right. Okay. The the the
standard Okay. The standard of like
performance for me is just so high. I
don't know.
>> Right. Yeah.
>> Jesus.
>> The standard of performance being don't
be a pedophile and don't make people
think you're a pedophile. Having so much
practice dealing with the same
accusations repeately should be well
practiced, but the burden shouldn't be
placed on me. The burden should be
placed on people who are leving PDF
allegations with almost no evidence.
>> Aside from the multiple times where
you've referred to yourself as a
pedophile and the multiple times where
you've expressed sexual interest in not
real life, children
and the multiple times you've explained
like how you how you used to have across
the road from children because you were
worried you were going to do something
crazy.
dense.
Straight up. Okay.
Straight up. It makes no sense. Anyway,
like you've had to deal with these
allegations for like two and a half
years now. Each time you explained, if
people don't get it, then it's just a
move on next random BS at the wall move.
Okay. Sleepy was here the entire time.
Okay. For two and a half years. Okay. Uh
guys,
guys.
Just a drink. A martini shaken, not
stirred.
>> Food shops may
>> Kirby, thank you so much for the $5.
Okay, I appreciate that. Thank you. Um,
guys, people need to understand
how long I have dealt with these
allegations. How long? And it's like one
of the most popular allegations out
there. Okay, how long I have responded
to these things over and over and over
again. Okay,
>> too long. Okay, too long.
I am black build. Okay. I think that if
you're not comfortable watching me, then
don't watch me. Okay? If you want to
watch me, then watch me because in my
opinion, I would rather be in a
situation where I am comfortable with
myself the way I am right now than it is
I don't know trying to do something like
just like it makes no sense. Whatever it
is what it is, okay? And you know what?
I I don't think the onus should be put
on me. If you want me to be more
popular, I think you should defend me.
Okay? I I think if you truly care about
it, you would defend me, okay? And show
some evidence for it as well. All right?
Because I know who the defenders are,
and I don't think any of the people
criticizing me right now are the
defenders, okay? Because I I need I I
need at least some kind of showing that
you actually mean what I'm saying in
good faith, okay? Like, yeah, I don't
know. He's just Yeah. Wait, what? Where
is this even coming from? Is it or is it
Dan? You guys sound similar.
>> Okay, we don't sound similar. And also,
I don't think you get to say that when
I've said it one time and then you
immediately go to a stream saying
someone should swat my kids and harass
my wife and kids more. And I think to me
that's one of those
I DM'd you. I was like, "Hey, you know,
like can we deescalate a little bit?"
And then you're like, "No." So that's
where I went to. It wasn't until
afterwards. It wasn't until afterwards I
had to deescalate and you refused to,
right?
>> They're a pedophile. So that's kind of
>> um just a little over the line. Just a
little over the line.
>> Just a little pedophile,
>> bro. That was completely like I I I
didn't even know what the [__] they
were. The overlapping audio is is just
completely like [__] How do I join
your biker king? you know, to be a
defender. I I don't know, dude. There
there's no official food shops defend
squad. Okay. Like people defend me
harder than I defend myself. Okay. At
least
>> Oh, they just left. They
>> Oh, got it.
>> And that's why I criticize his
parenting. Okay. True. That's why I
think it's a reasonable Oh, yeah.
Macabas, by the way, cut out the entire
Chaa debate. Oh my god, dude. That's
probably going to be a separate like
segment on the side channel. It just
interrupts the entire flow. Okay. It
just interrupts the entire flow. I need
to get back into the zone. Okay. Cha.
No, no, it isn't that I dislike you.
It's it's that like it it it kind of
interrupts like for people who just want
to see my reaction to anything else like
Yeah. They don't want to sit through the
entire debate to see escalation. Okay.
That's why I think it's a reasonable
escalation. Okay. I hope that your wife
gets harassed more at work. Okay. Holy
[__]
>> Oh, is still in here?
>> He's behind here.
>> [__] chat.
>> It gets a little riskier. Don't worry,
guys.
>> Can't even defend themselves. If they
would like to join Oh, okay.
>> No, I don't. No, there's no defense. No,
I mean, no, no, no. My defense is this.
Okay.
>> If they would like to join, then come
talk. We're in the [__] DG1.
>> Like, okay, if I say something like
this, like obviously I already turn off
all the Dan fans. You know what I mean?
At this point, I already turn off all
the Dan fans. So, it's like,
>> yeah, I don't care. I don't want the Dan
fans to be my fans, actually.
>> I think I'm good.
>> Yeah,
I hear that's been happening.
>> Oh, you needed to appease Dan so then
you can get the Dan Vans. No, I actually
don't want the damn fans. Okay, I think
I'm good. That's what I heard.
>> Just remember, every single battle I
pick is justified. Okay, just want to
just in case anyone wonders it might be
unhinged,
>> right? Of course. Of course.
>> So angry, dude.
>> So we justified no matter what.
>> Where is Victory Ridge?
>> It's almost like this is the inevitable
result of having a bunch of
schizophrenic autists filling a
community that have been brainwashed
into believing that if anyone commits
any slight act against you. Anyone
slightly inconveniences you online,
that's actually a attempt on your
livelihood and all options are on the
table from that point on. It's almost
like there's like a inevitable negative
consequence of having a bunch of retards
that believe that following you around
and and choosing as a you know
45year-old very bored man to weaponize
that community for your own end. It's
almost like you know one of those live
by the sword die by the sword kind of
moments. Don't you think that was as
much as I side with Dan is absolutely
true and this is just
this is leopards eating his face. Let's
be totally serious.
There you go. Go back.
>> This is like All right.
>> And why would I take it back? There's no
reason for me to take this back.
>> Let's go. I've done
>> Make sure to sub lock this so A can't
preload it for content tomorrow morning.
Oh, dude. Are they going to cover me
every day, bro? Oh my god.
Really? So cringe. Okay, hold on. How do
I How do I bot lock anyway? Holy [__]
Bro, he pedal. Yeah, of course I don't
feel bad for him anymore. Yeah. Or for
his wife or for his kids. What the [__]
Of course not. I hope they get blocked
the VOD. There's no reason for me to
block the VOD either. It's like
whatever. I don't know. I don't really
care all that much to be honest. They
can like again, by the way, if you guys
don't know, okay, because people are
trading like people are trading as if
like people were treating me as if like,
oh yeah, by the way, um,
>> I've never heard of your allegations
before. Don't you think your allegations
are [__] insane? Yep.
Brianna Woo, I kid you not, okay?
Brianna Woo and Counterpoints have
farmed me before. They've had their own
podcast and they farmed me for five
episodes straight.
>> If you if this is the first time you're
hearing about this, all right, I'm
sorry. Okay.
>> Yeah. Like like Yeah. You need you need
to you need to
>> This is old. Stop talking about it. This
is old. Stop talking about it.
>> Someone's already said that before. You
can't just do it. This will work. This
will work.
All right.
>> Yeah, that's about that was the main
thing. Um,
>> okay. So, they were saying that they
tried to deescalate and you ignored
them. Can you explain about that?
>> No, that's not true. They message me.
>> Screenshots.
>> Um, they they've posted them. It was
this uh first off, Mr. How many times
have you called me a pedophile in the
history of BG?
>> Thousands.
>> Okay. How many times?
>> What the [__] If I give a [__] that's
the dude. That's the dynamic between you
and Mr. Mutin. Yeah. I'm going to call
my friends horrendous [__] right? Like
if I'm Okay, just an example. Like if
I'm calling if I'm if I'm talking to
like Muks in private, okay? I'm just
going to be like, "Yeah, whore." Just
kidding. I wouldn't say anything like
that. But like, yeah, but I wouldn't
call anybody else like a [__] Like why
the [__] would I do that? Like there's
no reason for me to do that. Like if I
talking to Msaki in private, I would say
like super, right? But and they know
that it's fine. But like that's me and a
person that I'm familiar with. So it's
like what's wrong with that? Like
there's nothing wrong with that. But
obviously I would never call somebody I
barely know that, right?
What? Like this is not a good point in
any Can we just all agree that this is
not a good point in any way whatso
>> did I say that I was going to go into
swat and harass your [__] family
zero.
>> Exactly. Um I'm not cool with people
around like that. Especially people who
go and do it to their
>> Well, I don't know that. You can't
assume. I know that. I don't know why
they're assuming. I know the friendship
dynamic between Dan and Mr. Mutin is
also applicable to the dynamic between
me and Tan cuz we're not friends. I'm so
confused.
I'm okay. Whatever
>> stream afterwards seriously and I'll
never be and that's it. So, um, when
they said, "Can they deescalate?" I
didn't even knew that this clip existed.
I will never deescalate now. That is
just It's just We're just buying time
until you become JCO 2.0.
>> We're not friends. There is no
>> Dan saying he's going to turn food shops
into JSTOK 2.0. That's so [__] man.
That's [__] up. That's [__] up. He
said that about JTO.
That's [__] up, man.
I said something about Jook on Twitter
earlier
about that terrorist clip where Destiny
was saying like Jook's discord is like
terrorists. Alex Gekkmo replied to my
quote tweet of it. He says
Alex Gekko says here JTalk is a weapon
of mass destruction.
And I replied with, "Yeah, maybe if
you're a large Big Mac meal." That was
quite a good tweet about JTO. I thought
it was quite quite a good tweet about J.
I don't really give a [__] Um,
>> I'm pretty sure things you just told
them that you were going to [__]
ignore them and that was it.
>> And they said, "No, I'm going to keep uh
[__] talking."
>> I don't remember. If I were you, I
>> Oh my god. How many messages do you
think Dan has made about me at this
point?
>> Like, do you think Do you think that if
I were to search up like food shots in
Dan and Mr. Mutton and Destiny's DMs
that like
>> that hundreds of I did think about
posting that, bro?
>> Bro, you know what? I'm more offended
I'm more offended by the JTOK 2.0
allegation than than the whole like than
the whole like PDF [__] Okay. In a way.
Okay. in a mimi kind of way because in
my opinion, all right, that's heinous,
bro. You're telling me that I'm a you're
you're saying that I'm a rapist, okay?
Because JT Stoke is a rapist because he
[__] somebody who was not mentally
capable enough to consent to sex. All
right, like you're actually calling me a
rapist, okay? Like unironically a
rapist. So yeah, like I know I don't
like that considering how considering
how like I have my entire career is
built off of hating Jto. I just don't
understand how you can call me Jto 2.0
when all I've been doing is making fun
of him. But I think this just
projection. I think this projection
because he failed to defend Destiny as
well as I did. I I think that's 100%
probably that
>> show the I would just show the [__]
right now so we can move on with this
[__] drama because they're going to
try and make it seem like you completely
just like
>> here are the DMs. Oh, cool. Let's see.
>> There you go.
>> Okay. I I I'm going to I don't know why
Mutin is like the one that is a little
bit more mature than Dan here. Okay. I I
I'm sure Mutin wants to be there for his
friends, right? Like I think I
understand Mutin's position. He wants to
be there for his friend. Um because he
because again friend and friend, you
know, gang gang. Okay. I don't know. But
like I appreciate Mutin for for not for
trying to deescalate. I appreciate
Mutton for trying to deescalate whatever
situation this is, right? But I think
that Dan is just way too headstrong in
this situation, right? Because Dann is
clearly trying to push it into an actual
segment so then it can be pushed into an
actual video, which is what happened,
right? But then but then Mutin is the
one that constantly wants to move on
here. And honestly, I don't blame him
for that, right? There's jokes and
they're serious, by the way. But the
problem is is like I've seriously asked
food shops if they're a pedophile before
and they had typed dot dot. That was it.
So when I'm being told that she's a
pedophile multiple times and being clips
of her saying that she's a pedophile.
What do you want me to do?
>> I mean there's there's way worse [__]
that I've seen. I don't have it on hand.
One where they're like when I see a kid
on on the walking on the street, I have
to go to the other side because I get
nervous and I'm like what the [__] Like
>> all right, context. Okay, because of
Chaa. Okay, because Cha is all like, "Oh
yeah, you have to say no. You have to
say no." The reason Okay, this is the
only time I'm going to say this. Okay,
I'm never going to explain this ever
again. Okay, well I mean I'm probably
going to explain again, but for people
in private, I guess, or whatever,
because I've done that plenty of times
before. Um but okay again the reason why
I have said that is because again that
is a fear that is a fear that I have
expressed to my therapist because I was
so afraid of children. I was so afraid
of children because of like oh my god
what if I am a PDF? What if I am a PDF?
What if I am a PDF to the point where
like I'm constantly trying to ignore
kids in the first place because I don't
want to harm them. All right. So the
reason why I'm I'm trying to stay away
from kids IRL is because I don't
actually want to harm them. Okay? It's
because I'm anxious about that. It's
it's a it's a it's an anxiety thing.
Okay? It's not because I actually want
to harm them. All right. Also, by the
way, why would I ever admit this? Why
does this admit this?
>> This she's getting close to what POCD is
in the explanation here. The issue is it
doesn't jive with like a bunch of stuff
that she said in the past cuz the
explanations of PCD in the past were
like total nonsense. And the the
explanation of what what the therapist
said has shifted so much. Like you can
go back and listen to the old
conversations about what this therapist
actually said about Lolly shifted around
so much. They tried showing some email
or letter with their therapist
um that was supposed to prove it but
didn't prove anything. It's just that is
a total [__] show, man.
Total [__] show.
>> This on stream if I was actually trying
to hide something. Can somebody please
like explain that part? Like why would I
ever admit this on stream if I was
trying to hide something? If you if you
just if you just think about the logic
for like just two seconds, it just makes
no sense. It makes absolutely no sense
if you just think about the logic for
like two seconds. Okay. Anyway,
>> this is this is these are not [__]
jokes. These are like this is
>> I'm honest. Yeah,
>> I don't want to say
>> but but kind of but kind of what happens
is that I feel like I'm being punished
for my honesty. It's like whatever, man.
No, like in the past at the very least.
Okay. Like I don't blame people for like
misinterpreting like what I'm saying
because I wasn't the best at like like
explaining this in the past. But yeah, I
don't know.
>> Is it a real phenomenon phenomenon, bro?
And also like how how cocked is it that
like because Jews are constantly accused
of being pedos, right? Trans people are
also constantly accused of being Tedto,
right?
But instead of defending you, you should
understand. I think that as a Jew, you
should understand
how it looks, right? You want to be you
want to be a Pikmi for people who are
like anti like I don't know. You're
trying to be some kind of like weirdo. I
don't know. Like because
I I don't know. I feel like you should
understand more than other people. At
least I think you should understand more
than other people like how severe a PDF
allegation is. And it's not like Dan
doesn't understand. He understands. He
does because he said that for Steven
before, but he applies standards
differently when it comes to me. Okay.
>> Oh [__] Because how many people have
said that Israel is like a [__]
capital for sex offenders, right? How
many It's It's literally anti-semitic
that like Jewish people are a bunch of
like PDF sympathizers, right?
>> I I don't know. That just that just kind
of tells me that like Dan isn't actually
Jewish all that much. Like in my
opinion, um I think Dan uses the Jew
label to get a lot of sympathy for
himself.
>> But in my opinion, I don't think Dan is
a practicing Jew, nor is he a
>> If you're really Jewish, how come you
don't defend literally every pedophile
ever, Dan?
>> Dan, aren't you kind of a pick me?
>> Aren't you meant to be Jewish? I'm a
pedophile. Why aren't you defending me,
Dan?
Dan,
aren't you meant to defend every
pedophile ever? Is that what you guys
do? Hello
>> you or not? Okay. I've never seen him
either. I don't know. Like he's somebody
in which like And by the way, I just
want to say 77% 77% of Jews in the
United States vote. Dan doesn't even
vote. If this is news to you, if this is
news to you, okay, welcome to hell.
Okay, because Dan has not voted in any
United States election, or at least he
claims so. He has said that he's not
registered to vote in any way.
77% of American Jews vote.
Voting is one of the most Jewish things
you can do. Okay.
>> All I can say is L. Okay.
>> Community reposting them on my own
account. Here's my IVP ceasefire. Hey,
listen. I'm not okay with you calling me
pedal on stream. We're going to have our
massive
>> like why would you Oh, hold on. Another
thing is like why would you care about
um why would you care about rent like
renters's rights? Why would you care
about renters's rights and like renting
like [__] if you don't even vote?
Like I just don't understand. You don't
even vote. So why should you care? Like
why should you care about like renters?
Anyway, sorry. This is like kind of a
tangent, okay? Like this is a tangent,
okay? It's like not related, but I I
just still can't believe Dan doesn't
vote. I can't believe it. I can't
believe Dan doesn't vote. You know what
I mean? I don't know. Like, I would
gladly be called a PDF on Steven's
stream by Dan if Dan would just register
to vote. Okay? If he registers to vote,
I will no longer have an issue. Okay?
Straight up. I'll say this right now. If
he registers to vote,
if he registers to vote,
I won't complain anymore. Okay? Good
luck. No, actually, never mind. No, I'll
probably still complain. Okay? But I'm
just saying
>> agreements. We're going to beef. That's
fine. This is by however using platform
to call meto another step from trolling
you. I'm not okay with it. I'm sending
you this because a friend said I should
try recommendation. I agree. Blah blah
blah. Um this is all this is a fine
message in my opinion. What does Dan
say? Never mention my name again and
we'll talk about you again. Call a
random rants about me and [__] around.
Find out. Okay. I mean I'd say that's
fineish. Dan's a big aggressive here.
Dan is aggressive here. I'll be honest.
Dan, I criticize you for your ego and
you think calling me a pedo. Okay, then
fine. No truth. I think I made the step
to make peace and people can't say I
haven't tried now and this is not a
reasonable compromise of me. Consider
how my entire streaming career [__]
>> This ain't the hill fam. He probably
end. No. He said that on in 2020. No,
no, no, no. I I I think I sus out a
little bit more now. In 2020,
>> in 2020, he has said I I think people
have explained to me that he missed his
window to vote, to register to vote. I
understand. Okay. And then in 2024, I
think he doubled down and he's How
awkward is this situation? Do you think
it's for me? Or how embarrassing do you
think this situation is for me? It's
pretty damn embarrassing. Okay.
>> The fact that I'm trying to justify to
these two 40year-olds about my 24 year
old behavior or some [__] like that is
or 23y old behavior. What am I guys? I
can't be doing this anymore.
>> The chance that was actually motivated
are genuine concerns.
>> Why did Dan call food chops a pet in the
first place? Hey, do you want to just
get in the voice chat rather than type
in kick chat? If you want to get in here
and be a [__] white knight and
defender of food chops, come on. Let's
have a [__]
>> Wait, how why did Dan call food a pet?
>> Dude,
Zip Zip isn't actually like trying to Oh
my god. Zip Zip is not white knighting.
What? He asks a question and Mutin
interprets it as white knighting. Okay,
like notice how Mutin is no longer
deescalating, right? At first, I thought
that movement was going to deescalate,
but now he's no longer deescalating.
Like, okay, dude. I'm pretty sure he's
trolling Zippit. What? You really think
you wouldn't be dragged in? Hold on.
What now, bro? Okay, whatever. Yo,
what's up?
>> Oh, no, dude. Okay, wait.
>> Oh, this is annoying as [__] I
literally can't sit through this again.
Genuinely excruciating to listen to.
Legitimately excruciating. I'll pass on
that. That's enough of this VOD. Okay,
so my understanding is that Dan bent the
knee all about
>> Dan suffered the greatest aura loss of
all time and bent the knee to a
pedophile.
>> I don't think there's any personal
information here, so I think it's fine
here. So here is so
here's the condition of the ceasefire
and you
it was radiant that acted as a liaison
between me and Dan. Okay, Dan did not
want to speak with me directly.
This is why Dan is a real one. There is
no way he could be in Epstein's little
black book.
>> Thank you for the $4. Thank you.
Um
because he didn't want to. All right,
fine.
So,
essentially, this is the details of the
deal. Don't shout out. I have to. Okay.
Because otherwise, it would make no
sense. Like, you're really going to tell
me, "Oh, he didn't want to." Okay. Yeah,
whatever. Okay, fine. liaison, whatever.
It doesn't matter. Everybody already
knows already. You're already public
about it. It doesn't matter. Um,
so here's the conditions of the peace
deal. Okay. No, here's the condition of
the ceasefire.
>> And and I I'll I'll just say real quick
um what it's all about. Okay.
>> Um don't worry, I'll make it quick.
Okay. Gez.
>> Um so, basically, uh I criticized Dan,
right? And that has led up to a bunch of
[__] Um I guess in the long run, uh I
pissed him off. Um and he pisses me off,
right? Um but that doesn't mean that
we're good. It just means that we have a
mutual understanding. Okay. So we hit
the reset button. All right. We hit the
reset button a little bit. Okay. We're
not on good terms. Okay. But the peace
deal is still a thing. All right.
However, I will say, all right, um
basically here's the thing. I don't talk
about his family, his wife, his kids,
and he won't call me a PDF or imply any
such thing. Okay? Like, like I would
imagine like stuff like calling me a
rapist is also crazy. Okay? So, we both
agreed to match energy. That's
essentially what it is. Okay? We both
agreed to match energy
and because at some point we were
escalating attacks on each other, right?
Like basically because he got impedded
his family, right? It It was really just
food shops escalating for not really any
reason. I got to be to got to be totally
real here.
Wasn't really Dan escalating on this
one.
Not really Dan's fault. You You did He
had the a reasonable comment about you
potentially being a pedophile
to which you said his wife and kids
should be doxed and harassed,
swatted, have their life put in danger.
I'm going to be, you know, once again,
we we love Dan. We disagree with Dan a
lot of the time. In this case, quite
difficult. Quite difficult for me to see
the aggression towards food shop is
unjustified. Now, why is there a truce?
Why is he losing so much aura bending
the knee to this creature, bro? Um, and
I think part of that matching energy is
also this. Okay. Uh, I will not retract
that wife children statement on stream
until he also retracts the PDF stuff on
stream. But honestly, it's not needed. I
I'll be honest, it's not needed, okay?
Because I want to deescalate tensions,
so it's not needed. Um, but for people,
some people are talking about, you know,
are you going to retract your comments?
Are you going to retract your comments?
Well, again, right, we're trying to
match energy here. So, a retraction is
going to be met with a retraction, and
escalation is going to met with the
escalation. Okay? It's as simple as
that. All right?
And
yeah, basically if if the purpose here
is to match energy. Yeah. At first I
thought and this is a miscommunication
error. I maybe on my part as well is uh
I thought that what Dan was demanding
from me is I cannot commentate on him or
criticize him or criticize his character
or his views. Okay, I thought that was
the case. All right. But as our liaison
was communicating to me, okay, at some
point we negotiated
that I am allowed to criticize Dan's
character. Okay, off of that assumption,
off of that assumption, I believe I am
able to criticize his character, but
criticizing his character and
criticizing his personality has nothing
to do with PDF allegations. Okay. So,
the original conflict of of why it all
started in the first place, right? Like
why did it start in the first place is
because
criticism of his character led up to a
PDF jacket, right? A PDF allegation.
Okay? And for me, from my point of view,
okay, that's not just that is not just a
joke, okay? You shouldn't be joking
around with stuff like that. All right?
So, there you go. And I've also been
told I've also told that He believes
>> it wasn't intended that way
>> that I'm trying to turn.
>> It's not even in question whether it's a
joke or not. It's not a joke.
>> You've described yourself as a
pedophile. Lowerase P pedophile. Small P
pedophile
meaning a some kind of you know say a a
subclinical attraction to some form of
children particularly in cartoons.
That's what that's what she would
describe it as I think. And it's pretty
reasonable for someone to believe that's
essentially just a pedophile. It's
actually not that crazy of a position.
It's quite a common position.
Um, do I 100% agree with it? I'm not
sure honestly. Like, especially in food
shop's case, it's tough, man. The
statement is so inconsistent. I would
not, you know, there's many people
who've got lolly stuff like Lex who I
would stake a little bit of a defense
on. Food shops. No. No. I would not I
would not lay anything down and say,
"No, I I don't think this one. Not this
one."
>> Turn DG against him. Okay.
and whatnot. All right. And in order to
do that defense, he wants to turn DG
against me. Okay. So, this is basically
what we've been trying to do in the
background, like the secret war. Okay.
Now, with that being said, okay,
it wouldn't have reached this point.
Okay. Cuz I I noticed some comments
before. It's like a diminished like
they're going like, "Oh my god, food
shops, you're not significant. Okay, you
think you're part of a squad? You're not
significant or whatever." I would not
trust food shops with my hypothetical
kids or anyone's kids hypothetical or or
real. Personally, I this is not the sort
of person allowed to work around
children. No, there's way too many
statements that are crazy.
Tensions would not escalate to this
point and then deescalate if it weren't
for the fact that he is also taking
losses on his side. Okay. So, while on
our side, we can count the bodies and
whatever, right? Okay. Again, I'm not
like literally referring to bodies or
whatever. But I'm saying like in terms
of it's it's damaging both of us. Okay.
Because it's damaging both of us, this
is why we're deescalating. Okay. So for
anybody who says, "Oh, you're conceding
to Dan Dan and W." No, it's because
we're we're both like losing out on some
stuff. Okay. It's not in our best
interest to pursue a war. Okay. It's
not. And neither from Dan's perspective
is there an interest. Okay. He has also
said, I think from the liaison that he
really wants to deescalate. So
deescalation I will provide. All right.
And we will both deescalate them. All
right. I wish that you know he has come
forward to tell this to me himself like
we would DM each other so I don't have
to rely on radiant to do the leazisoning
because honestly I I I don't know like
with matters like I I just think it's
really gay. Okay. To have like a middle
communications person. Okay. I think
that's incredibly gay in the in the age
in the age of like in the age of
communication in this sphere. In my
opinion there's no excuse to not do
direct contact. Okay, no excuse. Um,
especially if you want to be serious
about the escalation. However, I will
still respect his wishes. I will still
respect his wishes. Did Radian send
screenshots? No. And I don't need it.
Why? Because I'm putting it all in
Radiant's name. Okay? So, if there is
any miscommunication, if there's any
miscommunication or there's any mistake
or anything,
you guys know who to blame. All right?
So, putting their own radiance word.
Okay? That's what I'm going to do. Okay?
No screenshots, no anything.
Yeah.
Um,
what else? What else is there?
Okay, I Okay, I want to clarify. Okay, I
didn't send screen chats cuz I told Dan
I was going to tell him stuff. I didn't
want him screenshots. That's fine. Okay,
that again, perfectly fine. Whatever. It
doesn't matter. Okay, another thing is
who knows how long the ceasefire is
going to stand. Okay, me and Dan are we
are both volatile people.
>> Okay,
>> we are both [__] So, so I have to speed
this up here guys cuz we are trying to
get through this bit now because guys my
understanding is that as much as I've
said you know there's a truce there's a
ceasefire Dan's [__] Dan's bent the knee
to the to the [__] nons
my understanding is the ceasefire is now
essentially off again and that food
shops [__] it up within like an hour of
this stream basically
>> people all right people have also said
oh Dan will never stop Dan will never
stop no you understand I'm different
okay
Dan is Dan is kind of a snarker in my
opinion. Dan's kind of a snarker. Okay,
>> here we go. Here we go. So, this is
>> the way that he kind of conducts himself
in the space. Okay,
>> I think this is part of what [__] it
up. So, saying Dan is kind of a snarker.
>> Dan is Dan is kind of a snarker in my
opinion. Dan's kind of a snarker. Okay,
kind of. All right. The way that he kind
of conducts himself in this space. Okay,
I'm the anti- snarker. Okay, that's it.
I snark snarks. So,
I mean, it is what it is. Okay, which is
why which is probably why like Yeah,
that's a thing. Let's move on. Okay, I'm
going to ban Radian real quick. Okay,
Radiant, I appreciate your help. All
right,
>> but also you're annoying.
>> Probably should have listened.
>> You can DM me still. All right, just
know that I muted you. Okay, to be
frank, I decide when it ends. All right,
I just when it ends. Okay, bye. So,
okay, with that being said, that's it.
That's all I have to say. Now, I end.
But not before I ban Radiant, okay, for
outststepping his bounds. Okay, you
don't get to control my stream. All
right, I control where I end this
segment. Okay.
Okay. Now, any other questions? Well,
and and here's the thing. Okay. I'm
happy I'm happy as long as I'm happy as
long as I still get to criticize his
character and he gets to match energy.
Okay. Dan gets to criticize my character
because that's matching energy. Okay.
Dan gets to call me a piece of [__]
However,
calling me like for example, if I call
Dan a piece of [__] I do not expect him
to elevate to PDF allegations. Does that
does that make sense? Hopefully, I'm
clear on this. Okay?
Right. Okay.
So, there's a difference between
criticism of character to allegations of
PDF. These are two different things.
Okay? If you don't think they are
different, you're crazy. Okay. This is
the entire drama is that there is a step
of this. Okay? Which is what happened.
Um, we want 180 like Jay Stoke.
If you want to believe it, then sure.
Okay. After all, I keep saying that I'm
going to one day betray Destiny, right?
Based.
So, what I'm going to now do is that I'm
going to cover the Dan segment this
morning because I think it's fair. Okay?
Because I have the right to respond. All
right? I'll do it nicer and I'll do it
cognizant of the ceasefire just mainly
because just mainly because it just it
just recently went like this. Okay. So,
what I'm going to do is I'm going to be
trying to be nicer. Okay. Okay. I'm not
going to be as unhinged. All right. Just
in the interest of the peace deal. All
right. Um Okay. All right. Let's cover
my segment on anything else. Okay. And
zip zip call. All right. Let's do it.
>> Great job.
>> Uh like security cam hooked up.
>> Sure.
>> Switch that cam whenever he walks out.
>> That's a good [__] idea. I agree.
>> Good content right there.
>> Uh I want to use the right word, so give
me one second. Mhm. Okay. Yeah.
>> Content driven.
>> Well, okay. Yeah,
>> that's that's why I think so. Yes. Young
and content driven. And I have a small
sample size of you right now.
>> I I agree that you have a small sample
size for me. So, someone being young and
content driven, that's enough to
>> give the impression that maybe I'll flip
like JTO.
>> Yes. Yes. 100%.
ignoring like any other like Dan like
right after you had said that said that
uh there there's teams and that food
shops and I are on a different team.
>> I Yes, I agree. I think that you and
Chops are
>> Okay. Okay. Okay. Hold on. I I want to
play the context. Okay. I I I kind want
to play the context. I thought you were
going to skip the anything else segment.
No, I'm just going to be nicer. Okay.
Cuz I have the right to
>> put this mutton guy in shackles.
Stop. Stop. Stop. I kind of agree, but
also it's hard to like totally hate him
when he's obviously there just kind of
for the money. You know, he's been
around for a long time and he's so much
less annoying than people like food
shops. I find it hard to have too much
hate
>> to respond. I'm sorry. I don't know what
to tell you. Yeah. If someone covers me,
I have the right to respond. It's as
simple as that. Okay. Yeah. Okay.
Anyway, that's just how it works. Let me
see. Wait, where's the clip? I don't
care. So, if food shop was to flip, then
you would probably be likely to support
your friend and flip his
>> Wait, hold on. Are we friends?
>> Okay, fine. Listen. Okay. All right. I
um
I I would say we're friendly. Okay.
>> Well,
>> sorry. I don't mean to be harsh here.
>> Well, first of all, I don't think food
chops would flip. Secondly, I probably
wouldn't.
>> Yes, you guys are friends.
>> Did you say so?
>> I'm pretty sure Dan says in the clip. I
I didn't watch it in like a few minutes.
Pretty sure he said like that I'm not
loyal to DG or you said that
>> like a coworker. Like a friendly
coworker. Yes, I think of him.
>> I don't know why you would I don't know
why he would think that. I don't know
why that
>> he thinks that you're loyal to your
friend. Food chops.
>> I don't know why.
>> Who else would be more likely to flip
than you in Chops?
>> Being loyal to D.
>> Who would be more likely to flip than
you in food chops?
>> I don't think No, I Zip Zip. No, Zip
wouldn't flip for me. What? No.
>> I I don't, by the way, I don't think Zip
would flip around. I really don't think
so. I really do not think so.
>> Radiant. I guess we could make an
argument.
>> Flip.
>> No. Radiant was the one who brokered the
peace deal.
>> You think that that's like
>> I think you have a I think you currently
have a 20% chance to flip. I would say
food drops in my mind.
>> 90. Maybe 99. I'll put it at 90.
>> Bro, I feel like I gave up everything to
defend Destiny. Bro, what the [__]
>> I have food in my mind. What do you
mean? What did you have? What did you
have that you gave up to defend dude?
What
>> is a ticking time bomb that and they are
going to flip. She is absolutely going
to become a hate watcher in my opinion.
>> A destiny hate watcher.
>> Oh, big time.
>> Why would you think that?
>> General vibe of
>> You know what? We got no actual reason.
>> I got a six sense, man.
>> You don't get to say no actual reason
when we've predicted a thousand people
doing this in the past. So, yeah, I got
a six sense
>> before doesn't mean that.
>> What? Oh. What does flipping mean? What
does flipping mean?
>> What does flipping mean? Because I think
you're talking about like maybe
>> Oh, okay. Now we need to define
flipping. All right. Okay.
>> One day in the future, I'm going to
distance myself away from Destiny. I
fully agree. I I think it's only a
matter of time before like me and
Destiny cover different things and then
I'm just no longer a part of DG anymore.
I'm just simply an associate and I'm not
really an order anymore, right? Like I I
fully agree. I fully agree with that.
Right. If my if my content creation
lasts long enough or whatever, then
yeah, of course, at some point there is
going
>> What the [__] else are you going to
cover other than Destiny?
>> Going to be an Exodus. Not not like an
exodus in the bad sense, but in Exodus
in like the naturally distancing sense
and like I'm pursuing some other project
or drama or anything like that. I think
they mean anti-fan. Yeah, that's what I
think they they mean anti-fan. Because
for me, I'm sorry. I just can't see
myself doing that unless Destiny does
something incredibly heinous, right?
Like like immensely heinous, like
actually heinous. You can just say it's
just vibes and there's no actual like
evidence or basis to actually believe
it.
>> Uh I mean I got I got evidence and
basis. If you want I can find it. I have
to go through my DMs.
>> All right. Give me
>> I never I don't like how every morning
this is becoming like drama about you
and
>> Well, you talked about me, Dan.
>> Yeah.
>> That's a oneway street. That's a oneway.
I didn't ask for you to come in here.
That's a one-way street. I was talking
about you, not I'm going to come in and
defend myself. Whoa.
>> I don't think we really did much [__]
talking. You said that I'm on a
different team, that I'm not loyal to DG
>> dual loyalty.
>> They have potential to flip like J.
>> Well, yeah, I think so.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. They're not they're not
quite on the on the full, you know,
they're not on the Dan and Mutton team.
They're not on the Dan Mutton Destiny
team. That's for sure. They're on like
some substitute bench or something, you
know, some kind of like sister team.
That that is Dan's analysis there. Dan
Mutton's analysis there is true. I think
all that analysis is pretty true that
they're quite opportunistic. They're
there because no one else is. is they
filled a gap. I think the I think this
analysis is quite accurate. I think this
is quite true. The minor leagues. Yeah.
Yeah. Who chops on the minor league
team? Yeah.
Guys, that was actually a great time to
remind you. Okay. 38 people send your
likes on stream. Some of those 230
people and please move us a thumbs up
and clicking it or pressing a thumbs up
on the mobile device. That be
appreciated. If you want to take your
support one step further, you can donate
directly through a stream link and a pin
chat message. You can also buy a
membership to channel gift membership to
channel. give a whole bunch of
memberships around the chat. Buy a super
chat which highlight a message and read
that on TTS super sticker with your
YouTube gift. They'll be highlighting
chats to you. You can go discord.ggman.
Twitter.com or.com/quman.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
>> I don't think so. That's what I
>> really You don't think so? You have no
chance of flipping.
>> Earlier he earlier you said you probably
wouldn't. Okay. Well, there you go. I
have zero chance of flipping. Triple.
Yeah, I have no
>> Yo, thank you for the five gifted.
>> Thank you so much, Thiologist. Hugely
generous of you. Thank you.
>> You don't you don't think so. You have
no chance of flipping. Earlier he
earlier you said you probably wouldn't.
Okay. Well, there you go. I have zero
chance of flipping. Triple as. Yeah, I
have no chance of flipping. I'd just
stop streaming before I believe I have
no chance of flipping. Want to say
there's chance of flipping. I would say
at most like 5%. Also,
can can I just say that discourse over
who's going to flip and who's not going
to flip is gay as [__] The reason why
it's super gay is because why are we
talking about whether or not somebody
will betray an online cult, right?
Sorry, I'm calling DG an online cult.
Okay, I mean it not really. Okay, it's
not really a cult, but like why? It's an
online community. It's an online who who
the [__] why who cares? Like I feel like
people should have better things to
worry about, you know, than who's going
to flip and who isn't. Like, you can't
tell me. You can't tell me that me, the
person who literally covers people who
flip is like telling like I'm the one
telling you that there are better things
to worry about in life. Okay? Maybe get
married, maybe have kids.
I don't know why it's so hard for these
orbiters to imagine how they'll flip on
Destiny. You disagree with them all on
topic. He calls you a [__] [__]
pedophile and you hate each other.
We even That's an oversimplification
though. It's you disagree with them on a
topic. You know you're right and don't
want to drop it.
and he will do literally everything he
can to try and browbe you back into line
and make your experience around him and
in his community absolutely [__]
miserable
until you relent or leave.
All right, maybe take care of people
around you, right? Maybe take care of
your elderly. Like I I I just don't have
any time to to to to like guesstimate
whether or not who's going to flip and
who's not going to flip. It's just like
maybe I'll make some vague guesses. Like
maybe I'll make some vague guesses, but
this just seems like overall I'm not
blaming anybody in particular. Um
because this also includes DG Chat,
right? DG Chat does this all the time
and in Reddit, okay, and all the time
everywhere in DG chat. It's like, "Oh,
we're going to place bets on who's going
to flip. Who's going to betray Stephen?
Who's going to Who the [__] cares, okay?
If they flip, they flip. If they don't
flip, damn, bro. Then they don't ever
flip, okay?" But yeah, but don't assume
that people are going to flip
eventually. And the question of when,
not if. It's just so cringe. Like,
nobody got time for this, man. Anyway,
>> I'm one otherwise. I don't think you
guys know me well enough to think
otherwise. I don't think you guys have
spoken to me to think otherwise. Seen
enough of me think otherwise.
>> I I've already told you why I think
otherwise. I think you're cloud- driven
and I think that you have a good chance
of
>> Oh, yeah. By the way, I just want to say
that this is the job of a content
creator. Okay, notice how I'm debunking
the points. Okay, I'm not attacking
Mutton's character. I'm not attacking
Mutin's character. I'm debunking the
points, okay? On why I disagree.
That's the job of a content creator. The
job of a content creator is to chase
cloud. That's the job of a content
creator. You're supposed to chase cloud,
especially in the early days.
Yeah, you're supposed to. That that's
what you're supposed to do. So, whenever
somebody calls Very high level stuff
here.
>> Creator a clout chaser.
>> That's literally the entire job. Okay.
Anyway,
>> flipping.
>> Why do you think I'm cloud driven?
>> Because you join this stream all the
time and immediately insert your opinion
constantly.
>> I don't think that's
>> Idriven. If I were cloud driven, I'd be
>> doing a million other things.
>> Okay.
>> Like not arguing with you guys about
this.
>> I don't think that's true.
>> I would probably just suck up if I were
cloud driven.
>> I don't think that's true.
go to that location.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. And either way, just being cloud
driven doesn't mean I would flip on
Destiny like JCO because like as this
has happened with all a bunch of people
flipped, it doesn't really get you a lot
of cloud flip necessarily.
>> Uh I think
>> yeah, if he was cloud driven, he would
be appearance obsessed, right? Like
there would be evidence of like if you
really want to levy an allegation like
that, I I think you need to provide a
little bit more than that, right? Not
just like vibes. I I think I think that
Corontos is a perfect example of
somebody who is so much more cloud-
driven to the point where you can call
him a cloud chaser because he would come
onto Destiny stream every day and he
would argue about different subjects and
he would promote his stream every 10
seconds. Like literally every two
minutes he would promote his stream,
okay, non-stop. The link, the name, the
title, everything. I I just don't think
Zip Zip is on the same level as
Corontos, okay? I just don't think so.
I'm sorry, but I mean we are all cloud
chasers at the end of the day. You know
what I like especially if you're trying
to get like validation from an online
community then yeah of course to some
extent that is like cloud chasing right
um but the thing is is
that's negligible cloud chasing because
obviously you want to be respected by
your own community right you want to
maintain a good image in your own
community so
so you should be maintaining that right
like you trying to argue for your own
image is different from barging in and
doing something heinous and then
promoting your stream right like that's
these two things are different right
anyway
that
>> what I said earlier I stand by I think
food chops is absolutely in my mind
going to going to eventually become a
haywatcher
>> but still spiraling in in icy is that
what's going on is that what's happening
so stupid
he's cry he's crying that I pointed out
the fact that the only reason he cares
about the stupid line is cuz he molested
his girlfriend cuz he got to her first
is he crying about that
is that is that what he's upset about
think you have a chance of it but I
Don't think you will.
>> Yeah. And I think your statement
>> is he thought about going to bed
>> more reasonable than what Dan said.
>> Okay.
>> But I Let's watch a statement real
quick. Let's see what we said.
>> Maybe he'd have a better sense of
content if he got more sleep. Maybe if
he wasn't like totally,
you know, fried
all day, every day.
This guy would have a better sense of
content. It wouldn't be spending all of
his time listening to the most inane
Discord calls of all time. Guys, another
crazy leak. Is it any different from the
last one? Nope.
>> Can someone film me on the food shops?
Hey, the only takes I've seen from this
person is that Destiny has vindicated
for his court drama. The leftists are a
huge problem and that and Dan focuses
too much on Hassan and not enough on as
gold. What are the horrible takes this
person?
>> Oh, that is me seeing all the DJs say
they want Pisco and Fujab's orbiters.
>> Oh, yeah. Big time.
>> That was okay. I'm pretty sure that's
>> You know, I'm going to call it here. Big
time.
>> I'm putting it out there. Yes, big time.
You guys support your friend and nothing
I'm saying here is wrong and I I have
proof so let's finish yes 100%
>> I don't even think that's accurate
>> there
>> the friend part
>> the current people who have
>> the highest potential of just flipping
going Jtock
>> why not
>> food shops and zip zip
>> I don't think this up more we need to
get through this
>> takes they're going to flip the switch
like
>> I want the keys
yeah
>> that's a little extreme difficult ult.
You know what I'm saying? It's easy to
go and do [__] [__] when everyone
already thinks that you're How do I put
this? If you're like Harvey Weinstein,
it's really easy to go defend whoever
you want to. You know what I mean?
>> And this is why I would like to
reiterate that it's an uneasy ceasefire.
It is an uneasy ceasefire. Now, granted,
this happened before the ceasefire.
Okay, this I have to keep in mind that
this episode happened before the
ceasefire, so I have to grant them extra
charitability, right? Does that make
sense?
>> I do I do have ingroup bias. I do have
ingroup bias. Aiden just needs some some
tough love. Aiden needs someone to tell
him, you know, listen, you're
you're off a beaten track here. You're
you're going you're straying from the
path.
>> I'm saying this person's Harvey
Weinstein. I'm just saying if I was
Harvey Weinstein, [__] it. I'll go
defend Hitler. It's not like my
reputation is going to get ruined as a
result. It's not that it's not that
difficult. You know what I'm saying?
Like uh yeah, I don't I don't take too
many um I don't really give a [__]
>> Somebody There you go.
>> Okay. There's a lot there. Okay.
Firstly, I don't know why you think that
food shops would flip like Jay talk and
become Andy fan.
>> I'm show I'm showing the vibe right I'm
going to show you why right now. I'm
going to show you why right now. They're
nuts. That's why. Cuz they're [__]
crazy. They're like the type of person
that's like posting messages they have
with Destiny non-stop cuz and it's just
so unbelievably cringe, so unbelievably
parasol, like, "Oh my god, how can I
post this? Look guys, he messaged me."
It's like it just makes me want to
[__] die inside to be honest. It's
just pathetic. It's sad.
>> Uh, I will say in the future, okay, for
anybody who has an issue with me having
things that make you cringe, I will say
that the block button exists and you may
use it. And people that go that [__]
nuts one direction, the second it the
second it turns a little bit, they go
the other direction 180 degrees just as
fast instantly. That's what happens.
Okay, if you become obsessed with
someone and then they [__] do
anything to slight you, they become the
world's biggest anti fan. The world's
biggest anti
>> Wait, hold on. Isn't this my take? Wait,
who who was the original one that made
this take where I said like
>> this is like a quite standard take. This
is quite a standard take. You did not
come up with this. Neither did Dan.
Dude, I'm I'm amazed
either of you came up with this.
And yes, if you've been saying that, you
should realize how it applies to you.
>> The most parasocial people become the
biggest anti-fans after they flip.
>> Who was the one that made the steak?
>> Not you.
I'm pretty sure I was the first one that
made the steak.
>> All started out as the original one. Oh
my god.
>> Send me a facts cuz I just said some
facts.
>> Yeah. Who says food? So, I would love to
be able to speak and not be cut off. It
would really bring me some [__]
pleasure if I could get a [__] word
in without
>> trying to speak and then I got talked
over by Dan. So,
>> it would give me a [__] pleasure to
be able to respond to you earlier asking
me why do you think Vu Chop is going to
flip. Here's why I think she's going to
flip. She is incredibly [__]
parasocial. As Dan just said, she thinks
that like Destiny is like super [__]
into her and watching her for two days.
So, he's literally not watching the
other bed for two days. Destiny, do you
watch me every day for the last two to
three days? Oh. Oh. Uh, bro, he's done
nothing but food shots for last three
days.
>> Yeah,
>> this person has crazy potential. And
this person is going to flip. She in my
opinion flip and she's on the Oh, I love
Destiny right now, but I love Destiny.
>> But why would that make me want to flip?
Okay, the reason why people flip is
because they're not self-aware. That's
that's also another reason. Okay, is
because for anybody who practiced like
actual stoicism like me, I acknowledge
that it's a reality that I am
parasocial, but I also acknowledge that
I shouldn't be um biased by that in a
really bad sense, right? As in I
shouldn't take any rejections like
harshly. I shouldn't take any kind of
denials harshly. Like just look for
example for example look at how I um
basically responded to the me getting my
perms and [__] right I didn't complain
much about that I really didn't in fact
if anything I've said that I said that
it was fair I said that that's a fair
move to do right so keep in mind there's
a difference it isn't just about being
parasocial okay because I will
acknowledge I'm super parasocial but um
but I think there's a difference between
having parasociality and recognizing
that versus um kind of not recognizing
it being in denial and then flipping on
the dime and then so then it just goes
the other way around in my opinion okay
because keep in mind there's plenty of
people who are parasocial towards Taylor
Swift okay of course or any kind of
celebrity but that doesn't mean they're
ready to become anti-fans the moment.
>> Yeah. And gringle would gringle was like
one bad day away from you know I can't
even make jokes what jokes I can make
when they step right out the gate once
the celebrity does something um once the
celebrity does something that they don't
like right in my opinion I I will say
right I will say that um if you look at
I'm getting [__] I'm actually getting
[__] right now. Oh my god I suck at
this game. I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry
bro. Hold on. Oh my god, bro.
You know what? This game sucks anyway.
Okay, but just so you know, this is why
people admit that they're massive uh
massive fans, right? Yeah. This is why
um people are honest about them being
massive fans of different famous people,
right? But then these people don't flip
because they acknowledge that they are
massive fans, right? They acknowledge
they have a parasocial relationship.
They acknowledge that, right? It's
otherwise there's otherwise there's
something wrong about being a fan of
somebody, right? There's nothing wrong
with being a fan of somebody. There's no
millionaires, billionaires are fans of
other podcasters. This happens all the
time. That doesn't mean that they're
going to flip all of a sudden. Yeah.
Again, like Yeah. I don't It's not a
matter of how parasocial you are. It's a
matter of awareness, stoicism, and
principles. Okay.
>> Very easily turn into I hate Destiny.
>> I'm glad Destiny's watching me. Oh, it
makes me feel warm for you. Go ahead.
Your turn.
>> Yeah, true. It does. And I'm any of
this. Yeah. Is obviously cringe. Okay.
Also, cringe funny to me.
>> But right,
>> none of that gets you to she's going to
flip because like recently hasn't been
as much on her crying
>> is cool with you guys who for all your
issues, whatever issues,
>> by the way. That's an issue by the way.
Okay. Uh, Destiny not being on my
stream. Massive issue. All right.
Possibly the greatest issue of all time.
>> Think about food chops. That's between
you guys and food chops. Like Destiny
doesn't really give a [__] about
>> I want to get through this. But if he
wants to call in when we kick, then he
can.
>> This [__] beef such drama, right?
>> Destiny just took yesterday.
>> Yeah, because I I went in and screamed
because I went in and screamed and then
I fully expected the perms to be taken
away and it got taken away. So I So I
can't just go Pikachu face, right? I'm
not going Pikachu face because I know
that it was going to happen. I accept
it. I accept the situation and I'm fine.
>> Yeah. Has she become anti now?
>> I It's been 8 hours.
>> 8 hours. No, no, you don't understand.
In 5 minutes, I'm about to become an
anti-an. Okay. In literally 5 minutes,
I'll become an anti. Okay.
>> But but that is like this isn't going to
happen from from taking the perms. This
is not going to happen.
>> Okay.
>> No. From perms. Yeah,
>> I disagree.
>> By the way, just FYI, okay, I was
defending Destiny before I even was
allowed back into the Discord server.
Okay.
I was defending Destiny when I was still
banned from the server.
banned not just per oh my god perma
banned for two years
>> so food you had said so much else going
on there was just so much else for food
shops to do in that time you know
>> it wasn't like defending destiny was
just s like the basic the only option
and the base impulse there were just so
many other options
>> your issues with shops has nothing to do
with whether she's going to become anti
like
>> it just isn't about that I don't know
why you think that and also
>> okay what is it about what is whatever
you know what do you think it's about
I would love to dance what it's about.
>> No, I'm asking why do you think we hate
food jobs? Go ahead. I'm asking why do
you think I'd love to be able to speak?
I'd love to be able to speak. Go ahead.
Okay. Instead of being interrupted, I'd
love to be able to speak.
>> Okay. Go ahead.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> Yes, you may speak. [__]
>> yesterday on stream.
>> Oh, wait. Oh my god. What? Why is Why is
this so hostile? What the [__] bro?
>> Okay. All right. Whatever.
>> Uh when you guys were going back and
forth about uh the truth with food
shops, whatever. Where it ended up and
where that conversation ended was Dan
had called food shops file. Food shops
didn't was not accepting that. wanted to
make a truth after and then refused to
make a truce and he said nope that's not
true that's not what was said
>> well that is no that that is that is
true as to what the conversation was
yesterday
>> no
>> what wasn't eventually gone to was why
did Dan call food pedophile whatever it
was beforehand I don't even remember was
it was probably some personal [__] or it
was something where maybe it doesn't
justify I call somebody a pedophile or
maybe it does but either way you could
just say hey I'll take that back if I
don't actually think you're a pedophile
or if you do actually think it and
that's cool but obviously going to be
[__] pissed
>> um someone that has called himself a
pedophile multiple times ironically and
there's I also have a clip of them
saying that like
>> done that right
>> okay I don't think Destiny has clip of
them saying that when a kid was walking
down the street, they were scared, so
they had to cross the street.
>> Except not every time they've said it's
been ironic.
>> The small P pedophile thing, that was a
serious point being made in a debate.
>> You don't think Destiny has
>> No, not No, not like No, not like that.
No, I do not.
>> Okay.
>> That's not even What is even a
conversation about right now?
>> I've given you examples of why I think
that you both know.
>> Hey, Star Hey, Star Chatter. Don't know
who you are, Star Chatter. brand new.
Well, you've been here for a long time
to say you have you know all this
[__] destiny. Lord, you've definitely
been here a long time.
>> You guys have no idea how hard I'm
holding back right now. These are the
ceasefire. Okay, there's a ceasefire and
I will not be the one to break it. Okay,
>> see that? That seems like that's
probably aged terribly, doesn't it? I
just get the sense of that that
statement has aged terribly
>> from my end. All right. However, I will
let you know
it is quite irritating to hear this.
Okay, that's all I have to say. Okay,
>> that's definitely not funny.
>> Can you stop being one guy and continue
with the conversation?
>> I don't give a [__] about a star
chatter. Can we just continue with the
conversation? Can you stop reading chat?
>> Okay, what is this conversation about
right now? What are we What are we
talking about?
>> What have we not
>> Well, now it's me defending food shops
because that's what it is. I can't
defend myself.
>> Yeah, I would rather defend yourself
than defend food shops because I would
if we continue to talk about you.
>> So, yeah. So, in the clip for well in
the clip for example, one of the things
that Dan said was like I don't value
anything that they've done or whatever,
right? Referring to both of us, right?
But just speaking for myself. Okay.
>> By the way, I'm 26. 26.
>> First of all, I don't care if you value
anything that I've done or whatever. Or
even I don't even know if I'm I'm not
here to like [__] say, "Oh, I've done
all these things." Whatever. Okay. But
also, women, you weren't here for quite
a while. You just came back. Okay.
>> I didn't say that. I didn't say that.
You're You're arguing with Dan and
you're having me as like a ghost here.
>> I'm not saying again, I'm not saying
that you did. Okay. I'm just Why did you
just say that last Why did you just say
that last question? Why did you just say
that then? because I'm about to lead
into explaining to you who was not here
for a while how it started in this
community uh and got [__]
>> I don't give a [__] It doesn't matter
to me. You're on your way over this.
It's not fire to
context here. I don't need it.
>> The absolute best of the best debate is
in DG DG now. Zip Zip and food shops.
That's their peak. That's their peak.
That's who they're sending out.
>> I don't give a defending myself from the
accusation that I could flip on a switch
>> and that there's a potential high
potential of doing it high potential. I
said I don't think you will. You said
the two people with the highest
potential to do it. Yes, that is
correct.
>> That's not a very high bar to clear.
>> That's not There's not many of you. No
potential. No, there's not. Yeah. So,
that's why you two are the highest. And
I even said I don't think you would.
>> Out of how many people?
>> I out of like three or four people
genuinely.
>> Okay, cool.
>> It's you and
>> KA.
>> So, for context, Mr.
>> I don't give a [__]
>> I got involved in this [__]
>> I don't care. No, I don't give a [__] I
don't care.
>> And knows and he said what he said but
no.
>> Guys, what does this have to do with me?
Why why do I need the context here? I'm
muted on my end for a minute. Like,
>> well, to be to be very fair, right, the
reason why you need the context is
because um I don't know like I would
like I would wager from my perspective
at the very least. It seems like Zip Zip
is trying to come in imicable, right? He
he wants a disagreement. Like obviously
there's going to be a disagreement.
However, right, he I don't think he's
make he's made any personal attacks so
far. I don't think he's done anything
wrong per se. He wants to talk about the
issue and that's literally it. I mean,
you can argue, oh, he doesn't need to
like um hop on stream. Maybe he could
have resolved this in private or
something and maybe that's why he caused
issues or something. But at the same
time, you know, I I just don't think I
don't think there's a matching of energy
here. You know what I mean? Like I don't
I I basically I think that Mutin is
going way more aggressively at this than
um than Zip Zip, which which by the way,
if you're if you're going to be like
this sure of yourself, if you're going
to be this sure of yourself, that's
fine. But you're going to need to
actually know what you're talking about.
You mean like the details of the case,
the details of what you're talking
about? Because like like for example,
it's kind of like Pisco going over to
Ethan Fleet, right? He hasn't even
looked at any um bada detailed [__]
about him. Um but he's willing to be
very very angry and argue about it for
like hours and hours on end, right? If
you're going to be very sure about
something, make sure you actually know
what you're talking about. But anyway,
whatever. All right. Yeah.
>> Do we give a [__] Because I don't feel
like he's responding to the [__]
arguments here.
>> Oh, wait. I didn't mean to serve you. I
meant to mute my mind. Sorry.
>> I don't feel like you're responding to
the arguments at all. And I just don't
give a [__] about it.
>> It's It's literally you, CFKA, and Food
Chops. And you and Food Chops are the
most likely in my opinion to turn. And I
don't think you will.
>> Okay. Pops up.
>> Am I Am I muted? Can I Can I speak or
>> I mean, you can maybe speak. I might not
I might continue to say I don't give a
[__]
>> You can not give a [__] You can still
just maybe let me speak. I don't have
the platform you at all if I don't want
to.
>> I want you. You're in here to respond to
the arguments.
>> It's so funny. Zip keeps trying to like
stand up for himself and put his foot
down. I'm glad Mutton is is holding firm
here. I'm glad. This is the thing, man.
This is the thing. This is the only time
they're good is when you hate the lower
tier Destiny orbiters more than one of
the higher tier ones. And you get to see
them get slowed. It's why it was so
great seeing, you know, Stardust
interact with some of these people
sometimes that were that we made. And I
only the only time I can really go and
it's not directly responding to anything
I have an issue with directly responding
to the potential of me flipping on a
switch like Jto. So I'm going to go to
my record and explain to you why my
record I think demonstrates that I would
not do that and I don't take timely
being accused of being potentially able
to do that. So can I go and explain
that?
>> I just don't give a [__]
>> Understand why TF is zip zip and how is
that not a slur?
>> Good question. He's the guy who showed
up at Pixie's court hearing to sit in
the hearing and like recount with
Destiny on stream how the hearing went.
Everyone makes jokes about how he showed
up to come on a car door handles and
[__]
>> But do you understand
you [__] me telling my face?
>> What I did but what I did wasn't [__]
you described aspiring law student.
>> So I don't understand do it.
>> Yes. Out of three [__] people, out of
three people, out of three people, you
had a high you had a potential to do
aggressive right now. So, I'm going to
[__] defend myself.
>> I I just I don't understand how you're
upset with me and not yelling at Dan
here. Dan is the one who said all of the
[__] about
>> Okay. No, I don't. Okay. We're throwing
Dan a little bit under the bus. Okay.
>> All right.
>> Yelling at me.
>> I'm not yelling at you. I'm telling you
I don't give a [__] because I'm trying
to tell you I don't care about what
you're going to say and you should
respond to the other arguments. This
doesn't matter to me. It's between you
and three people. It's you, [__] food
drops, and Kfka. Those are the three
people who come on stream constantly.
Cfka seems like a really cool dude. Not
aspiring lawyer, aspiring law student.
Correct. I don't even know if he's
studying anything at the moment to be
honest. I like I haven't heard him ever
mention studying at the moment. So I I
legit think this guy is just like a
[__] waster. I wish I was a law
student basically.
>> I really don't go [__] man. [__] I
accident clicked off like in terms of
it's it's damaging both of us. Okay.
Because it's damaging both of us. This
is why we're deescalating. Okay.
>> Sad
community, right?
%
>> I don't even think that's accurate
>> there
>> the friend part what the [__]
>> the current people who have
>> the highest oh
>> I fully expected the perms to be taken
away and
>> anything that they've done or whatever
right referring
to both of us right but just speaking
for myself
>> like three or you need the context is
because um I don't know like I would
like I would wager from my perspective
at the very least it seems like Zip is
trying to come in amicable right he he
wants a disagreement like obviously
there's going to be a disagreement
however right he I don't think he's
he's made any personal attacks so far. I
don't think he's done anything wrong,
per se. He wants to talk about the issue
and that's literally it. I mean, you can
argue, oh, he doesn't need to like um
hop on stream. Maybe he could have
resolved this in private or something
and maybe that's why he's chasing
chasing or something. But at the same
time, you know, I just don't think I
don't think there's a matching of energy
here. You know what I mean? Like I don't
I I basically I think that Mutin is
going way more aggressively at this than
um than Zip, which which by the way, if
you're if you're going to be like this
sure of yourself, if you're going to be
this sure of yourself, that's fine, but
you're going to need to actually know
what you're talking about. You mean like
the details of the case, the details of
what you're talking about? Because like
like for example, it's kind of like
Pisco going over the Ethan Klein [__]
right? He hasn't even looked at any um
bad epinada detailed [__] about him. Um
but he's willing to be very very angry
and argue about it for like hours and
hours on end, right? If you're going to
be very sure about something, make sure
you actually know what you're talking
about. But anyway, whatever.
>> Do we give a [__] Because I don't feel
like he's responding to the [__]
arguments here.
>> Oh, wait. I didn't mean to serve you. I
meant to mute him on my end. Sorry. I
>> I don't feel like you're responding to
the arguments at all. And I just don't
give a [__] about it. It's It's
literally you, CFKA, and food shops, and
you and Chops are the most likely in my
opinion to turn, and I don't think you
will. Okay. Cops up. Am I am I muted?
Can I can I speak or
>> I mean you can maybe speak. I might not
I might continue.
>> I don't give Jesus a slug, man. We skip
through all this.
>> I don't appreciate the characterization
to me. I I straight up don't think this
is true. Okay. Um I Yeah, I I just don't
think this is true. Okay.
>> So, I'm just going to cover it. We're
going to cover it.
>> [__] crazy. And you seem fine. You're
>> And by the way, okay. Um it's also it
also doesn't help that Mutin and Dan has
a lot of pull and sway in DG as a whole.
So if they if they decide to say things
that are not accurate and they spread it
around and and they're making opinions
off of that and character judgments off
of that, in my opinion, that's unfair.
Okay? In my opinion, humble opinion,
right? That's unfair. All right? That's
it. That's that's it. Okay? In my
opinion, that's unfair because a lot of
the hatred that people are putting onto
me are not are unjustified because they
base their hatred off of incorrect
information. Right? If you hate me for
who I am, I respect you. Okay? I respect
you. if you hate me for who I am. But
the problem is that a lot of people
don't a lot of people don't know who I
am. Nor
nor do they have an accurate basically
I'm talking about similacrim, right? I'm
talking about similacrim like a
similacrim of me is being made to be
used to attack me. But that's not the
real me, right? Which is uh what I have
issue with anyway.
>> Normal. You're okay. You're fine
because there's already multiple
inaccuracies in my minion.
>> Okay.
>> I think CFKA is in a different league.
I'm not worried about CF.
>> I'm not worried about CF in the slice
either, but I'm also not worried about
Zip Zip.
>> Why bring CF? Um h seems like you're
>> Yes. So argue with Dan. That's what I've
been saying the whole time. Yell at Dan.
>> Yeah, but you're the one [__]
talking. So shut the [__] up, man.
>> YOU BECAUSE YOU KEEP TRYING TO TELL ME
SOMETHING LIKE I GIVE A [__] little
bro. I don't care. It doesn't matter to
me. Talk to Dan. Jesus. My god.
>> This is the type of behavior that makes
me sus by the way. You know
>> what you're doing right now without
being
>> the way you're just the way you are. I
don't you know
>> I uh this like oh sussing people out.
Singing people in. Sussing people out.
Well, made everyone in DG hate Mr. Girl.
So, a lot of people never liked him
because he is a weird guy, you know?
He's he's he's a he's a divisive guy.
He's a strange guy.
But, um, it really started
basically
he challenged Destiny on the Fuentes
chicken and waffles thing and on
Destiny's inconsistent definition of
Nazi
uh, and won that argument.
So, a bunch of the people in the
subreddit were more on Mr. Girl's side
and then they all got banned. So, they
so they all either gave in and kissed
the ring or became Mr. Girl fans
instead. And then shortly after that, he
started getting into the arguments about
the subreddit moderation, which
obviously, you know, people who were
against him initially got more against
him. People with him got more for him.
And then he went ahead with the Anna
stuff and that was the final breaking
point where it's either like either you
realize then that Destiny's a total
piece of [__] who's been lying to
everyone for ages or you're locked into
the cult. You know,
I feel so from my perspective. Like I'm
just talking about from my perspective.
Wouldn't it be more fair to dislike
someone or to hate on someone after
they've done something bad? Not that you
suspect they've done something bad. Like
otherwise, that's just kind of like
witch trial behavior. You know what I
mean? You suspect that your neighbor has
done something, so you're going to
assume that they're guilty. right?
You're going to assume that they're
guilty. But when when in actuality
there's plenty of people who act really
suspicious, right? Like for example, I
can point out literally any chatter in
DG chat. I can point out any orbiter
ever or anybody who hasn't betrayed
Destiny yet and say, "Yeah, you know
what? I think you're sus. I think you're
sus. I think you're sus." Right? And
then but I'm not going to but just
because I think you're sus doesn't mean
that I'm going to say something like,
"Oh, I think you're actually going to go
out and have a chance of betraying
Destiny." That's I don't know about
that.
>> Supreme Court, you know, I know it when
I see it. Yeah, that's basically it. The
way you're [__] acting right now is
like high on the sus meter of what I've
seen in the past. That's all.
>> Okay. And I'm I'm happy for you on that.
Okay. I don't know if you remember. We
had a very reasonable conversation a few
Yeah. But I'm happy for you that you're
happy. Okay. Uh I don't know if you
remember. We had a pretty reasonable
conversation a few weeks ago where you
came in with the same [__] giving me
similar [__]
>> I didn't accuse you.
>> What's your understanding that I
>> can Can I speak maybe without
Okay. Yeah. But my [__] radar is just
going off the [__] charts here right
now. It's like it's like an enemy sub at
[__] 25 meters and closing.
>> I'm very happy for you that your radar
is going off the charts. Can I speak?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, last time we had a
conversation about this, I explained to
you to give you more context and remind
you, first time I joined anything DG
like on stream related was earlier this
year back in January. I joined Darius's
stream on stream that you were on and I
eventually ended up staying on Darius's
stream being a regular guest of his DG
after hours thing uh for the months that
Destiny went uh didn't stream after the
Pixie sub dropped and for a while after
that when he was still doing it uh I
ended up being like co-host basically of
the show for a bit uh where we just were
defending Destiny against anti fans and
debating anti fans and [__] Okay.
Eventually over the summer I went to D4
days stream talk about it and then
eventually I started streaming a couple
months ago.
>> Right.
>> When full time
>> when what
>> when did I ask? I'm sorry. Keep going.
>> Okay.
>> So you didn't ask but I'm explaining
this again.
>> Okay. That one saying like the whole
time I've been zip f has been
>> my come off as a bit of a cloud chaser.
Yeah. But that's fine, right? Does that
make sense?
Like I like I also am a like I'll just
admit that I am a cloud chaser. I am I
am a cloud chaser. But that's the job.
As long as you're not harming anybody by
being a cloud chaser, you're fine. The
only reason why people why being a cloud
chaser can be bad is because it makes
you feel cringe, I guess, and it looks a
little shameless and or it can be very
shameless or it can be in such a way
where you're actually harming other
people. Like let's just say you go
behind someone's back and you undermine
someone by DMing a moderator or or
something like that, right? About other
orbiters and trying to turn them against
each other, right? Then yeah, in that in
that specific scenario, yeah, you are a
cloud chaser, but the but the inherent
crime isn't you being a cloud chaser.
The crime is that you're willing to do
really bad [__] in order to chase cloud,
right? So So I I guess what I'm saying
is this is the space where everyone is a
cloud chaser, but how you chase cloud
matters, right? I feel like will abandon
your morals or opinions for cloud. Okay.
Yeah. Then I guess I guess we kind of
have different definitions, right?
>> Like exclusively different
[__]
>> Okay. Literally debating anti-defense on
this [__] taking heat from anti fans
for this [__] deating irrelevant
debating broken house J etc doing all
this [__] okay eventually food started
streaming or had been streaming was
doing Destiny defense similarly was
watching food stream I think eventually
called
>> yeah there's this [__] uh deflection
that this [__] idiot does and a lot
of [__] idiots do where like oh
really you call me a cloud chaser isn't
a good thing as a streamer yeah that's
not what's being said being like a good
streamer a streamer operates
intelligently is not necessarily being a
clout chaser a clout chaser is someone
who is unnecessarily or excessively
preoccupied with clout in a way that is
obvious to people around them and
off-putting. That's generally a rough a
rough definition of like clout chasing.
It's not just
creating content or trying to be a
successful content creator. It's
specifically you using the term cloud.
for pointing that out specifically
because they are doing something
excessive or out of the norm or
unacceptable obviously.
Well, then I remember talking about
what? Okay, top chops also in the
trenches for destiny at a time when Dan
you have left anything else for
reasonable reasons and moon you space.
Okay, now you guys are coming back and
that's cool. I like you guys. I've been
here for quite a few years. Okay, but
now you guys are coming with a lot of
heat.
>> Dan and aren't clown chasers because
they already have a cloud from being
friends with Tiny for a long time. All
I'm going to say is that people who have
already made it shouldn't be pulling the
ladders up behind them. Okay. Um,
this space is hard. This space is really
difficult. Okay, it's really really
difficult to
get anywhere in this space. Okay, um and
everyone suffers from survivors bias
where you only see the people who
succeed but the people who are dead
don't have a chance to actually speak
out. So you get this inflated sense that
as long as you participate in this
space, you will become successful when
that is far from the truth, right? Um
for every single one successful content
creator, there's going to be 500
unsuccessful content creators, if not
more, because of the percentages and
like how many people tried content
creation and failed, right? Um, if you
made it, one of the best things you can
do ever for the entire space is to help
others up, right? It's one of the best
things you can do, which is probably why
Destiny unironically tries to support
smaller content creators, though he
stopped because of all the drama [__]
right? Which makes sense from his point
of view specifically. But this is why
larger content creators typically do try
to give smaller content creators a
chance, right? And why they like
battering up orbiters like that. It
isn't it isn't just to solidify power.
It's also like a part of it, right? Like
I would say like the fourth reason is
also as a charity move, right? So, and
it also makes the space healthier. It
also makes the space healthier because
you don't want only the old heads
around, right? You don't want the only
the old heads around because if you only
have the old heads, um you end up with
only people like Miz K and Hassan and
all these people always at the front of
the news and always influencing the
discourse. They'll have more power and
money and the audience power to try to
solidify power behind them. Um and then
it just leaves very little room for
other people to grow because they become
the Amazon businesses of the streaming
world, right? Um Amazon buying out
smaller shops to turn into their own
Amazon shops, right? essentially
speaking, right? So, which is why it is
good to try to promote some orbiters and
promote a sense of independence into
these orbiters as well as you shouldn't
be handholding them all the way, right?
Like Hassan does. Hassan wants to create
cult members, not actual like charity
like people, you know? That's yeah,
that's what I believe at the But anyway,
the point is the point is just that
that's it.
>> Food shops, I don't give a [__] Okay,
there's back and forth there. Oh,
thanks. But I've never said anything
about you guys and I'm catching a lot of
heat and I don't get it. It's [__]
strange. So, the heat that you've caught
is me saying that you're one.
>> So, dude, this Zip Zip guy is He's like
begging for approval. He's begging for
an easier ride, right? It's like so
shameful. What? Why are you guys talking
[__] I'm trying to be in this
community. You guys just talking [__]
about me. Bro, just stop being such an
embarrassing spur. So desperate all the
time. And they might have a better
impression of you. No one likes
desperation, and you are so [__]
desperate.
>> One of the most likely to flip out of
three people. And I didn't think you
would.
>> But also like again, if you've made it
in this space, I guess good for you.
We're all happy for you. You know what I
mean?
>> But uh yeah,
>> that's a lot of heat to you
>> from you, right?
>> For you.
>> Okay. Dan also agreed that he didn't
think you would flip. I don't know what
he thinks now.
>> First thing, Whoa, hold on. First thing
that came in when I joined this call was
I have very little issues with what you
said except that I don't think I have
potential to become an anti fan and flip
a switch. Whenever you said that, Dan
went well. So Dan doesn't agree with
that, right, Mr. Man? Maybe you're gonna
speak for him, but or maybe he's gonna
walk that back. I
>> I think so. My guess what Dan thinks
right now is he probably thinks that
you're on the same level of food shops
slippage now. And another reason that I
think that he thinks that is because if
you're out there and you're in the
[__] constantly, you're way over
invested in all this [__] At the time,
Destiny didn't [__] know you. And if
you're on all these streams [__]
defending him and
>> wait, hold on, hold on. I don't Okay, I
don't like this characterization either.
Just mainly because Okay, frankly.
Number one.
>> Yeah. The reason you like this
characterization describes you [__]
obviously. But this is just true. Yes.
Obviously the most obsessive freaks if
they find out they've been lied to,
which they will,
>> they're going to flip like crazy. Yeah.
>> Okay. What I do is not up to you. Like
what I find interesting to do is not up
to you. Okay. Number two,
>> there are people out there extremely
strongly despite having no reputation,
despite having no investment into that
reputation either. Okay.
>> Yeah. And they would be [__]
suspicious of those people. Obviously,
>> the reason why they do it is because
they think it's right. is because they
don't like it when they see somebody
getting false allegations or getting
canceled um without just reason. Okay?
Nor do they ever want to know or neither
do they ever want to be found out
either. Okay? Trust me. Another thing is
there are people um if I can if somebody
can make a career off of defending
someone from false allegations, I don't
think that's a bad thing. I think that's
a good thing. Right? You want there to
be, you know, at least some capability,
right? some capability or room to expand
in that direction, right? Somebody who
can actually get some credibility in
order to debunk allegations, right?
That's a good thing, not a bad thing.
So, if other people picked this as a
hobby or even as a job, right, me, then
I don't think there's any real issue
here, I guess. Yeah. Anyway, whatever.
>> Going super [__] hard. I just want to
finish my point. If you're going super
[__] hard, you're way over invested.
>> I'm holding back a lot. I will say I am
holding back a lot. You guys can tell,
right? I am holding back a lot. All
right? I'm not going to say anything
crazy. Okay? Don't worry. Like again,
yeah, just
>> and you're going to be way over invested
when he eventually uh does something
that you don't like, and you're going to
go on the [__] complete opposite end.
So, you're overinvested on one side that
he likes, and you'll be over invested on
another side that he doesn't like.
That's That's my point.
>> Exactly.
>> Okay. I think I'm invested to a
reasonable amount.
>> No, you're hypered.
>> We're on dare to stream to talk about
this [__] And I eventually just kept
going on dare to stream to talk about
this [__] So, streaming a couple months
ago, a few months ago to be another
person in the space. People had been
asking me to stream.
>> Yeah. You J 2.0 little bro. You J 2.0.
>> Another person in this space who's on
this side.
>> They as [__] being in order. Whatever
the [__]
>> right? That's all. Okay. Is it ever has
been? I don't know why like a whole
thing. I don't know why it never had to
be.
>> Do you think you have more sick
tuitiveness than Lykan did?
>> Sick tuitiveness.
>> What's this with Lykan?
>> Probably there was audio coming by.
>> Well, many people probably thought that
Lykan would never flip.
I don't think that's the case.
>> Really?
>> He hasn't been around long enough.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> I haven't been around long enough.
>> Not if you're not if you're saying that,
brother.
>> Wait, how long has Zip Zip How long has
Zip Zip been around?
>> Does anybody know?
>> Hey, it's coffee. Can I Can I stop real
quick? I'm not going to I think Zip can
speak for himself. I'm not going to
fight his battles.
>> Put this to Damn,
>> but as um like Mr. Man, I think it's you
guys been here the longest and I'm not
going to second guess you guys. I mean,
one thing I will say is, you know, I
think it's fair that you guys are
protective of your friend Steven and all
that stuff. I just wonder like when you
guys do this open speculation about like
who people flipping. I mean, it's good
memes the community likes it. I get it,
but like it does kind of it kind of like
sets an expectation and it it does kind
of make people uneasy at least as
orbiters because it's like, you know, I
mean, like I think Zip for me everything
I've seen from Zip is that he cares
about Steven.
>> Come on. 10 toes down. I want them to be
uneasy. Come on, Dan. Give it to us.
Come on, Dan.
>> Is the same. And I'm not gonna like sit
here and defend either of them, but like
it feels a bit like you guys are
undermining people that want with Steven
by doing this open speculation. I mean I
mean these married men so concerned with
who wants to be friends with Destiny.
That is a great question is that is a
great question.
That is a very very good question.
>> It just means you guys don't mean it.
Like if that's the case fair enough I'm
you know soy for saying it but it does
feel like kind of you're coming at
people that that are trying to help the
community. Do
>> you know how you would say that you
would know a relationship is strong?
because you can't really know how strong
your relationship is until it's been
through some trials and tribulations.
Someone that's always been
>> Kafka is probably one of the only
lawyers in this entire space that I
actually
that I actually respect. A lot of
lawyers come into this space and they
just don't know what they're talking
about. But I really like Kafka for this
reason. Okay.
I really do genuinely
>> wealthy, never had to face adversity
with their spouse, never had a big
argument, gone their entire life without
having to really deal with any drama.
They don't know how good that
relationship is. It's only moments like
this where you find out who's actually
in it for the long haul versus those who
are only there as a matter of
convenience and clout ability to get it.
And I think that conversations like
these are important to see how people
react to external stimulus suggesting
that perhaps they are not a uh good
person and go from there. And also the
what I would classify as amen to a meme
thing. You know who's not in here
flipping out? Radiant who's growing on
me honestly a little bit. Would you say
as well Mr. Mitten?
>> I I think Radiant is a really chill
person and I'm very surprised at how
well
>> they haven't got memes. Yeah, they
haven't gone [__] mental. Um, even
though I see that they're still doing
like a little bit behind the scenes uh
type of [__] That's a
>> Yeah, behind the scenes peace brokering.
You mean Yeah. I mean, I guess because
behind the scenes implies behind the
scenes implies that they're doing some
sneaky [__] but like what Radiant has
done is is that he's done something
good, right? He hasn't done something
bad. He's done something good.
>> There is no behind the scenes here.
>> Something that they can can do. The
thing is is almost as important as what
you do in the first place. No, I'll just
say that um I think that uh um it's not
so much for you. I just genuinely feel
that.
>> Yeah, I'm gonna be wrong. I tuned out a
bit about mentally tubers. Yeah. Well,
this is true. I tuned out a little bit
about law tubers because I just
>> I think I think my brain just almost in
a sort of like an attempt at inoculation
almost like I was getting a disease just
uh shut down so that I wouldn't have to
be exposed to it that protected me from
it. But I assume whatever this person
just said about Lord Tubers was totally
[__] and there's no basis and was
probably shot at Pisco.
Let's sit down to how mentally ill they
are.
>> Okay. Like literally mentally unwell.
Not a good person. No one that
>> true
>> now. Okay. So, food shops is mad as
Okay, here we go. This is the truth
breaking.
This is the truth breaking, isn't it? I
feel it, man. Look how mad. Look how
pissed off, bro.
>> I feel food shops is mentally unwell.
Okay. Like literally mentally unwell.
Not a good person. No one that I
>> You just [__] up, Dan. You just [__]
up big time.
>> I will not contend with that.
Uh,
I go to therapy. Okay.
>> I want to be around with and then things
that they say makes me incredibly
[__] sused out to be around them.
That's it. Like there's nothing more
that I can say than that is just like
across the board. Uh, there I see almost
no redeeming qualities except for the
fact that they're willing to fight with
people that Destiny aids. So, they're a
useful tool, but they sure as [__] ain't
my
That's
brutal, bro. That's harsh. That's [__]
up, man. Holy [__]
It's just like across the board. Uh
there I see almost no redeeming
qualities except for the fact that
they're willing to fight with people
that Destiny aids. So, they're a useful
tool, but they sure as [__] ain't my
friend. and they sure as [__] ain't
anyone that I want to hang around with.
And if someone came in here saying that
they wish that [__] uh Mr. Mutton's
wife would get harassed or swatted, I
would never talk to that [__]
ever again. So, I'm happy for them to go
out and uh you know, do whatever and and
you know, be a useful tool, but let's
not [__] joke.
>> Oh my god.
>> You know what? What did you think was
going on here?
>> You know what?
>> I've been tapping into Buddhism
recently. Okay, I'm at peace.
I'm at peace.
>> What did you think was going on? What
did you think the whole self here was?
>> I see the world before me and I smile.
>> Ourselves and say that this person is
like a friend of the community or
anything along those lines. They're here
for clout. They were irrelevant before
and they'll be irrelevant after. And
eventually when that happens, they'll
turn to [__] hating Steven like they
always do because that will be the next
way that they get clout. No, I'll
probably try to get my old USPS job
back.
>> That's all that these people typically
care about. That's it. Um I stand by
that pretty good. I'm
>> I'm not here to scold or tell you what
you can or can't say.
>> Okay. Well, that's uh
Wow. I uh I'm a little bit speechless.
Okay.
>> You know, I think for some of the newer
people that are trying to come in, like
there's already a pretty strong
resistance by the community against
people joining as orbiters. Like I faced
that. I know Zip is facing that and
whatever. And it's just like I I mean
like it just feels to me like I I hear
you.
>> Ceasefire. Ceasefire. Okay. All right.
Got to remember the ceasefire. Okay.
>> Got to remember the ceasefire. Okay. Got
to remember the ceasefire. Okay.
>> On, you know, people need to be tested
relationship matters. I think you kind
of but like us coming in here and
speculating before we see that moment.
Um I don't know. It feels a little bit
unfair to me, but I mean I'm not going
to
>> I think we were I think we were maybe a
little bit unfair to Zip Zip and they
shouldn't have been lumped in with the
with food shops.
>> Yes. But the way they reacted has not
been good.
>> has not been good. Now I
>> Yeah, I just want to say one more thing.
Um I do think that
>> we I I think a lot of people who come
into the I I don't know. It's a cringe
term. the orbiters. I I think a lot of
them don't know when the [__] to join
and when the [__] to leave and when the
[__] to shut up in the call. It's a
skill that you have to learn. I think
you're very good at CFKA. You come in,
you do your launch.
>> Not relevant.
>> So, you're going to tell me what's not
relevant.
>> This is what's actually is being like
the accusation.
>> Zip Zip, you're [__] up, dude.
>> Yes, it zip. Zip, you're [__] up
right now. Okay. Pisco had the patience
for this. Peace had the patience for
this in VC.
Dan don't got the patience for this.
Dude, you have you have gravely
miscalculated this situ. You've gravely
misjudged the situation.
100% does getting there.
>> One second. Zip. I think it's the deal
is is that I think that people like and
this is, you know, something where I
think it's it's again people are leaving
room open for speculation. Zip, I think
you join and you want to contribute and
all that stuff and that's great. I think
for some people they feel like you have
contributed zip, you are now done and
you can sign off or something and so
that's why people tell you to get out
and whenever you
>> Oh yeah, Radiant closed the peace deal
like 30 minutes. 30
>> Yeah, this is after people look at that
and go and people could Yeah. And that's
and it's fine and I'm not telling you
what to do or not, but people will then
say he's doing this. Why is he doing it?
It's probably for clout. This guy's
cloud driven. Now, I'm going to look at
all of his actions through the lens of
him looking for clout. And I don't think
that about you, but whenever people do
that, who do they think about, right?
They think about the Jewalker. They
think about Hassan. They think about
Bosch. People that are very clout driven
and how they've acted with Destiny's
relationship. And I don't think it's
necessarily fair to lump you into that,
but I do think it's like it's something
that like I would
>> also another thing um I would like to
say is like sometimes it's kind of like
a self-fulfilling cycle, right? Like if
you treat people like animals, then
they're going to act like animals,
right? I'm not saying that if you treat
someone like an animal, then um they
should like, oh yeah, then they should
go feral, right? Oh, they should betray
someone if you act if you treat them
like someone who's shitty, right? But it
it certainly doesn't help that DEG chats
like standard like the culture in that
server in in that chat at least like
their standard for orbiters is immensely
high. Like you have to be pristine. You
have to be pristine in terms of not
being annoying, not being disruptive,
not being whatever. That being said, I
do not fulfill that criteria and I'm
fine with that. Okay? I don't fulfill
that criteria. Understand that I'm very
annoying to a lot of people.
>> Okay? But that's a problem because other
people won't be okay with that, right?
Like that's the issue at hand.
>> All right? So, I'm not defending myself
on this. I'm not defending myself on
this. However, I will say that it's just
the fact of the matter that if the
entire community treats one person in a
very disfavorable way, then sometimes
they just hap like part of the part of
the reason like part of the thing that I
kind of try to observe and the reason
I'm saying this as well is because one
of the reasons why I like cutting the
anti-in [__] is because I like to find
out why people turn is because I want to
figure out why people turn as well. And
yeah, I mean I mean if if if DGG has a
machine that constantly spits out
orbiters um that eventually betray
Steven or betray the community, yeah, it
doesn't justify anything they have done.
It really doesn't. Okay, it really
doesn't justify anything the anti have
done. However, at the same time, people
didn't have to become a villain in the
first place if the machine was a little
bit kinder, right? if the machine was a
little bit kinder and a little bit less
crazy like asking people to die asking
like people making jokes about aring
other like raping other people or um uh
being PDFs and [__] like that. If they
were just a little bit kinder, maybe
then people wouldn't go turn into
villains, right? Because because at some
point you have to ask yourself, right?
At some point you have to kind of ask
yourself, all right, you have to ask
yourself, what is the common what is the
lowest common denominator of every
single one of these betrayals? At some
point, it either relates back to Destiny
or it relates back to GG chat, right? It
isn't just that, oh, 80 people happen to
be all horrible people at the same time
in a row, right? Does that make sense?
Like the probability of that happening
is so immensely low, right? But it's but
it kind of feels sometimes that DGG is a
machine that converts
good or bad people into villains, right?
Like there is a 80% to 90% villainy like
turn rate for good and bad people that
are put into DG, right? Does that make
sense? Like like it's it's a conversion
machine to turn people into
backstabbers.
>> Yeah.
>> Expect that kind of speculation from
people. It's one of the reasons why I
personally try not to overstay and it's
one of the things where like but but
also
>> I feel that's probably the mystical
critique. I do not have as much of an
investment in an online presence. I'm
more interested in just finding content
for the community.
>> And by the way, as long as you keep
blaming other people and as long as you
don't question your own community or and
as long as you don't look at your own
chat or anything like that, the longer
you're going to remain in
>> Why don't you potentially look at the
streamer who runs all of that
>> or is that is that why people keep on
doing the things that they do? Okay,
again, I just want to say I am the most
anti- anti-fam person ever. Okay, I
really am. I am genuinely the most anti-
anti-fam person ever. Okay, I really am.
Okay, from all the content that I have
produced, from all the so I I think I
have like expertise to speak on this.
All right, however, you also need to
understand where they come from and why
they are the way that that they are.
Okay, nothing justifies their unhinged
behavior, but you can certainly
understand and try to reduce the
possibility at the very least of people
turning against you, right? You're
you're never going to guarantee that
people won't turn against you, but you
can absolutely take steps to improve the
community in such a way where people are
not like that, right?
>> Yeah.
>> And and then having that go. It's not
really I don't really I'm not really
interested in being a personality. I'm
more interested in just finding ways for
the community to enjoy, you know, being
together and doing stuff. Well, you also
like jumping on and like being able to
say your thing on the stream and like
get your like opinion heard, right? Like
I would assume so.
>> Um, sure. That's fair. But like the the
other side of that is like whenever I'm
done doing that, I go back to just being
in chat, right?
>> Yeah. I'm not saying that 100%.
>> Sure.
>> I was trying to say that in like a
that's a good thing. Like that's a
that's a good thing that you can do.
Like it's good that you can go in there,
get your opinion out, and have a
meaningful conversation with Steve and
then when you don't have any more, I
guess, then you you you go out. You're
you're out of there. So, I guess my
whole point was like I think it's I
think people just need to have more
self-awareness of when their time is
done. Um, like when I'm going to give an
example here when irrelevant joined and
was talking to Steve, I was pretty much
shutting the [__] up. And then Zip Zip
joined and then Zip Zip tried to like in
my opinion insert themselves into that
conversation and took a lot of it when
that should have been a cool moment for
Steve to talk to [__] irrelevant. And
that was just a that that is a micro
that is a microcosm of the issue in my
opinion.
>> I'm reporting not relevant, right?
>> Sorry, I meant I Yeah, I'm
>> Yeah, I'm that's fair to think. Okay. I
don't necessarily disagree. Okay. I
talked more than I expected to whenever
I hopped on because I hopped on. I don't
remember what it was about. I think it
was about imputing hundreds or some [__]
like that. It ended up being more about
that because it became a back and forth
where was on me. I think I already said
cool things about it as well.
>> But oh finished.
>> Yeah, I joined to say something. I to
say I said it.
>> You disagree that cool but I wasn't
there to like [__] cloud farm for my
ride. Right.
>> Right. And but two things that like one
I think like whenever especially on
Destiny stream like Destiny's a big boy.
He can ask people to leave if he doesn't
want them to be there. Yeah. Another
thing is that I I don't like this. Okay.
All right. I promise it's not a personal
attack. It kind of it it Okay, listen.
It's a little bit of a personal
criticism, but I think it's warranted.
Okay. I think to some degree people are
people who are friends with Destiny are
parasoially trying to control his stream
because they have spent a long time in
DG. Okay. I understand where they're
coming from. I understand what they do
and why they do things. Um at the same
time,
>> yeah. Okay. But like if weird content on
stream more conversation with Steven
than with the people that come on and
two, you know, I think that like it's
really hard for me to look at like Zip
Zip coming on having genuine arguments.
Maybe people disagree with these things
like that and maybe he overstates
whatever, but like to me I think it is a
it is a bit of a jump for people not
putting on you. I think a lot of people
are putting this on Zip a lot, but he's
very cloud driven. I think that he's
really on. He's figuring out where
places and all this. He's trying to
build something for himself and I think
people are kind of holding that up
against him a lot. Not to, you know, you
know, blazing too hard here, but yeah,
that's all I want to say real quick.
>> I am not mad at Zip right now.
>> I don't think you are. All I'm trying to
say,
>> all I'm trying to say is people need to
know when to join and they need to
understand when Steven is doing a
YouTube.
>> Dude, I'll be real. Okay, I I know I've
I've made it very clear. I [__] hate
Nolan.
>> I am actually slightly interested in his
version of the Odyssey. I am actually
slightly interested what that'll be
like. I feel like that's the sort of
thing Nolan could do well. You know, as
much as I hate most of his other films,
I feel like he's a sort of director that
could do well with having like one of
those doing doing like some of those
like, you know, really wellknown,
done a million times, very clear stories
and just making it kind of like his own.
I feel like that that could go kind of
well. I think the biggest problems with
Nolan are when he's got too much
freedom. Like that's why the Batman
films are actually half decent. You
know, Momento is just like tryh hard and
[__]
Anyone that super rates that movie, like
it's not it's not [__] It's like mid,
but people that rate that movie
literally piss me off endlessly.
Inception as well. It's like got some
cool scenes, but
kind kind of mid as a film and
unoriginal as [__] I didn't watch
Tennant. Interstellar blows. and Stella
[__] blows
like moment
could have absolutely
>> okay I would argue is probably a little
>> been a YouTube video from what I've seen
>> I think Zip Zip unintentionally joined
at just the wrong time you have to you
have to have pick and choose your
moments when to join you shouldn't be in
there all of the [__] time especially
in my opinion if you're not his I don't
know if you guys are friends so I I
would assume that but I have no idea I
think Steve has a very close group of
friends and it's usually uh I've not
read the Odyssey in the original what
I'm trying to get here is if you read
the Odyssey something I had to learn you
have to pick and choose lose your time
to [__]
>> Oh my god, dude.
>> Okay, so a couple things there. Okay,
first of all, I have no like delusions
on my level of friendship with Destiny.
Okay, for one thing. Secondly, I don't
give a [__] if I'm made by the
community, I don't care.
>> Okay, that's a go.
>> Thirdly, sometimes like like yesterday.
Okay,
>> like I just
>> wow guys, let's play the game problem or
projection. Okay, for every single issue
that people bring up about Destiny or
not about Destiny or something else, why
am I walking like this? Okay, you guys
have to guess in your mind, right? In
your mind, is this problem or is it
projection? Okay,
>> the call and was just like interjecting
every now and then.
>> Yeah, Oenheim was No, I didn't watch it
though. because we're playing darkers.
That was fine.
>> I literally just stayed because it was
funny. People kept going every 5
seconds. Zip zip. It's funny as [__]
So, I stayed.
>> Okay.
>> Like the time to do that. It's purely
just it's just funny to me.
>> But that was a fine time to join.
Nothing was happening.
>> Yeah. And I don't I don't that. But just
as an example that, right? Okay. The
thing that's fair enough. I think
there's a difference between there. I I
could say, "Yeah, maybe I cut the
conduct a bit." Okay. I joined to talk
about what they were talking about. It
ended up taking a bit more time than
expected. That's all it has to be. Okay.
Okay. But I don't think I don't know why
it has to mean I'm self-driven. I don't
know why it has to mean any of anything.
>> This is it in the past. Listen, you have
to cry now. Okay? If you cry, you'll
gain 50 sympathy points. Okay? You have
to. You have to right now. Okay? Now is
the time to old. Come on.
>> Yo, I'm joking. Okay.
>> Uh [__] Hello.
>> You have to [__]
Jesus Christ. I've harped on it though
multiple times in agree. And Dan's just
not really. Well,
>> I disagree mostly from I mostly he's
being very nice. He's a See, yeah. Why?
I heard about Oenheimer.
I heard it was kind of mid and I heard
that the Einstein Einstein scene was
[__]
[__] and like a Marvel cameo and I
feel like that sort of [__] Marvel
cameo [__] That doesn't work for
historical figures within the last 100
years or so. Really, really does not
work at all for that. It seems really
goofy.
But if you do it for like mythological
characters, you know, you have
characters from from uh like Greek
classics, that's a whole different
thing. Greek Greek epics, that's a whole
different thing. You know, those are
sort of like there are different
characters that have a bit of permanence
and cultural relevance in a in a way
that's
sort of similar to to a superhero. You
know, there it's not just [__] this
guy who died in the last 100 years. This
just dude, you know that it's kind of
hard to hit the cameo with the with the
score when it's some boring ass [__]
like some old dude.
>> He's the I guess you could say he's the
good cop in this situation. Um I just
even throughout this conversation, I
just see so many of the things that uh
like you just should have just shut the
[__] up and you would have been fine. I
don't even know why you came in here.
This whole thing has made you look 10
times worse. You should have just been
in chat, called me a [__] [__]
said said I was speaking and you would
have been good to go. This is like the
worst thing you could have done.
>> Okay, that actually you've kind of
you're saying Iron Man and Martin Luther
King, you've kind of
>> thrown me off a bit because that one
Spider-Man comic where he meets Obama,
that shit's awesome. And if they made if
they did that in the movie, I would I
would actually saw point and laugh very
hard.
I think that was awesome.
>> You say you don't care, but you I can do
it because
>> I think I think this is perfectly fine
in this. But you know what? I'm a little
biased. Okay, I will say I'm a little
biased. It's not because I cover for Zip
constantly. It's because I'm beefing
potato.
>> How are you Jewish?
>> Fire. Case fire. Remember, cease fire.
Okay,
>> the call to talk about it. Why are you
It's fine. I don't care. It's fine. My
own actions have made me look. That's
fine. I can
>> No. Okay. Okay, guys. I haven't made a
single personal insult, nor have I gone
unhinged this entire coverage, right?
Like, let's be very clear, right? The
entire time. The entire time, I have
just not been unhinged in any way,
right? Okay. All right. Just making sure
in case anything happens after the
stream. Okay. Oh, okay. Take that. Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, he's
>> I I just I'm not sure what to what to
say to you. Like even recently just now
you said like, "Oh, yeah, Destiny was
talking with IRI and it was something so
that's why I joined because I wanted to
talk about it." It's not, you know, like
I don't even think it clicked to you.
What what like what the comments have
for us?
>> Okay,
>> you would do it again.
>> Do you think I don't understand what the
issue people have with that is?
>> I get it.
>> Would you do it again?
>> I agree. I do it again.
>> Let's say I comes in here and he starts
talking about some [__] you really care
about. Would you join?
>> I might do it differently.
Okay. You would join differently. What
does that mean? Like you would join
another voice channel and conversation
differently.
>> Okay.
>> Versus when I came on it came back and
forth.
>> You just don't understand.
>> It's not about
the topic cuz he didn't know that much
about it as anything else.
>> I agree. It's not about me. I don't
think it was about me.
>> But you're still joining when this
happens.
>> When's the last time I was on stream?
When was the last time I was on stream?
Maybe you can answer that one.
>> Before a couple weeks ago, whenever.
>> Yeah, I know the trailer leaked and
showed Punisher for Spider-Man. I think
um I believe some of the earlier link
leaks as well about Hulk being in it and
[__]
So, we'll see though. We'll see. I think
it's going to suck. Personally, Doomsday
might be barely watchable just for the
like, you know, old characters, you
know. I I feel like Robert Downey Jr.,
Dr. Doom can't be that bad,
but that's got to be watchable.
I want It's not going to be good.
It's not going to be like
particularly interesting, but I can
imagine myself watching it. I can see
myself, you know, kind of be like, "All
right, this is okay, I guess."
>> That happened.
>> Yeah.
>> Many many months.
>> Okay. Do you think that was a good time
for Zip 45 to come in and dominate the
conversation?
>> That's what people were waiting for.
>> I I think uh gun DC
right now.
>> I didn't expect to dominate the
conversation. Okay. It became a back way
of things
>> with what I had brought up. I just bring
up and it was going to be a minor thing
and I was going to shut up and see if
there was another thing to talk about as
well. I don't remember. So,
>> do you understand how that looks like
you're cloud driven when someone who
hasn't been on the stream who okay who
has a YouTube channel and everything
joins and you immediately join and then
take over the conversation? This this is
another example of how I I get there of
like, oh, Zip Zip could turn, he's
[__] cloud driven now. It's just not
a good time to join for you.
>> Well, I I don't feel as though Zipu has
done that during that conversation, but
I don't even know if there's a real
issue in the first place cuz I don't I I
have forgotten I have forgotten the how
that original conversation looked. Um I
remember covering it, but I don't
remember Zip Zip actually barging in
there and doing some [__] [__] But like
I don't know. Um yeah, I don't know.
>> In my opinion, you have perms, you can
do whatever the [__]
>> Also, I would say Zip is parasocial, but
I don't think he's clock driven as hard
as people believe him to be. I think
that he's parasocial and he wants like
validation from the community, but
that's like everyone, you know what I
mean? Not only is that everyone um but I
I I don't know. Like he's always been
very quiet voiced, right? You want it's
Steven's Discord. I don't control it. I
just think it is a poor time for you to
join when someone who is another big
influencer joins the channel and is
talking to Stephen. Um, and this is a
big moment where they can both like have
a [__] conversation with each other
and instead you joined. I think that's
just a bad thing to do.
>> Oh, I think we can have a difference of
opinion there. Okay. And that's fine.
>> But that
>> the Batman 2 is not going to rape, bro.
I I still haven't seen the first Batman,
>> but I don't I don't trust people's takes
on it from what I've seen.
I I saw I've seen like the ending scene
where he's saving everyone in the
flooded place or whatever.
I watched that scene and that
that was terrible. That was awful.
I really like Robert Patterson.
So,
um I wish it was good, but it looked
bad. Look quite bad. I I I would prefer
I really do hope that they're using
Patterson for the Brave and the Bold
movie, but I guess we'll see.
I guess we will see.
>> I I don't I don't know how else this is.
I understand what people think the
things they do about me. I disagree that
I'm just trying to
>> I'm gonna say I understand why brokering
a deal.
>> We have literally not I don't think I've
had this [__] [__] comment for
like at least a year. What do you even
like?
I I've seen your name in chat before.
You know, there are many times where I
will sit here and autistically rant
about something that I'm incredibly
interested in, series or show or movie
or whatever or game that that I actually
really do like that I will sit here and
rant and argue. People tell me that's
not as good as you're saying and I will
sit there and argue firmly. This is it's
the most annoying thing people say. I
remember this [__] Flornney actual [__]
I'm not joking. [__] Flornney
who was from Destiny's community. He was
a cuckold. an open car cold would come
into spicy chat and support all of his
[__] [__] slop and wife's boyfriend
media that he would that he would enjoy.
He was an actual [__] He would talk
about his wife [__] other dudes in
front of him
and he would come in and talk about all
of his awful media that he enjoyed and I
I would I would rip on it and say it was
terrible and all the this guy would say
that all the time. What do you even
like? What do you even like, man? What
do you even like? Do you even like
anything? It's like the most [__]
thing you can possib Obviously there's
plenty of things I like. I don't like
what you like cuz you got [__] taste. He
was happy about it. Yeah. Yeah.
Going on streams endlessly being like,
"Yeah, I'm I'm a [__] and I don't care.
It's awesome. I love being a cock."
>> Isra Palestine is so hard now. Okay, I
will not elaborate. Thank you,
>> dude.
>> Just going to have to agree to disagree.
Am I right? Is that your be that cool?
Okay, that's
>> where must still be on Chud's channel,
right? No, I understand IBP. I
understand the struggle.
>> I think we're going to have to agree.
>> It's hard to hold back. It's hard to
hold back.
>> You should have just not come in. You've
made it worse for yourself. I don't know
what. Oh, man.
>> I don't care if I made it worse for
myself.
>> I cannot speak or I'll be in trouble. I
cannot speak or I'll be in trouble. I
cannot speak or I'll be in trouble.
>> I just want to see this [__] break the
truth already. Holy [__]
>> On stream to talk to people opposite of
what I expect of not caring.
>> I don't care if people hate me for my
own actions.
>> So why'd you come in here to defend
yourself? You don't care.
>> I care if people hate me because of
>> So middle management. So you care if
people are talking about you. You don't
care if people are talking about you.
>> That's funny. That's a funny comment.
>> I mean, do you have to translate?
>> It was so cool being an underdog. It's
lonely AF at the top.
>> In a chat like this, you could swing
your blade around and only hit enemies.
It was crazy. It's just totally crazy.
People never truly appreciate how much
different all this [__] was when we were
first in Chud's community.
>> Understood this a couple minutes ago.
>> So funny.
>> He's saying that he doesn't care if he
makes himself look bad. He just doesn't
want people to think that he looks bad.
>> I need to I need daytime in spaceport to
see [__]
>> Hard to understand.
>> It is a little bit. And all this does
come down to what the public's
perception of you. Do you care about the
public's perception of you?
>> Sorry.
>> I care that it's an accurate perception
of me.
>> Okay. I think that I think that there
was like constructive criticism given
about how long he's he comes on a
stream. Those guys need to discuss.
That's fine. I think the part where kind
of goes past that is when people there's
the discussion about him turning or
whatever. I don't think
>> I hear what you're saying there. I think
bifurcation is really Reddit thread.
Yeah. I was responding to Reddit thread.
I think we made a broader point about
who we think will like have the ability
to turn or whatever. Um, is that is that
productive? No. Um,
are we
>> Well, for was like a Discord log
into VCs just like berate him and, you
know, [__] with him and
there a few like that. That's why it was
so good. You know, that's what Stella is
talking about.
>> Especially if you read Dubbies Super
Chats. Well, I'm not going to read I
don't want to read DB super like in my
opinion. This is pre content. Like I
really enjoyed watching this in a way
like in a sadistic kind of way. Okay.
But black edit um the yeah oh god the
peace go actually can I delay peace go
please it makes me sad.
>> It's fine for us to call food shops out
there in personally I think that that
does more good than harm because I think
food chops is a bit of a crazy one. Um
should I zip in there? Probably not.
Would I do it again? No.
>> You don't have to take anything back but
you know tip or tie. Um you know I if
you don't take anything back I will not
take anything back. Okay. But the
ceasefire is still a thing. Okay. So, we
will not make any new escalations. We
will not make any new escalations. It's
just that if you do not react, then that
will also not retract. If you do not
retract, that will also not retract.
>> Okay, we have to speed through this. I
think I have to get to the good stuff
here.
>> I mean,
you're going
>> again. I am not escalating in this
string so far. Okay. No escalations
here. All right. I'm just criticizing
like 99% their views, their opinions.
Why is a great defending zing? Right.
>> You hard saying you will not
>> and explain why. I mean, not that you
won't flip, but just that you're not
going to be any fan like Okay. Say that,
right? But
>> yeah, everyone does say that. Um but uh
I mean you know it's not it's not it's
not me any fan of that said um I'm
inclined to like I'm inclined to you
know the saying shut the [__] up when
someone's like letting you win. Maybe
you should do that right now. Okay.
>> Well you don't understand it. Dan is
being nicer. He could go so [__] this
guy [__] [__] If you're targeted
your time is [__] limited. I don't
care. But it's time to make a [__]
prediction. Six months tops guarant. Put
it on the [__] books. Like you're
actually [__] [__] It's like
you're you're brand dead. You're brain
dead. Like there's nothing I can do to
help you. This is how I know you won't
[__] make it. God Jesus. Wow. Okay.
Yeah. Okay. Don't make it, bro.
Dude, I got
>> I I'm sorry. I really don't think that I
I really don't think that um Zip came in
with that energy. I I think that I think
a statement like that is warranted only
if
>> Yeah. You can't figure it out cuz you're
a [__] [__] too. But he has come
in with [__] energy.
Mad [__] energy. Desperate [__]
energy. Like, it's just not good at all.
It is very embarrassing. He's desperate.
He's nervous. He's insecure about his
position in this in this community. He's
he's trying to like suck up to the
bigger figures in that in the community
to try and like plead his case. He's
realized Dan shut off. He's speaking
more to moot and he's making this
appeal.
It's just it all comes up. It drips with
insecurity, drips with desperation
and he's stupid and he's really dumb.
That's the problem. It doesn't matter if
he's being mean. Okay, that's not go
that's not the only thing that can cause
someone to stop getting annoyed with you
is just being rude or mean.
>> Start escalating the conver sorry not
overall but like I'm talking the
conversation. Okay, like over the course
of the conversation like I would
understand if Zip came in super hostile
and he was being anticipating and [__]
then yeah I would understand something
like that
>> dude. Okay, I mean that's I'm just
saying
doesn't get it at all.
>> Tip wasn't offensive. That's not the
problem.
>> Okay, listen. Okay, I'm going to throw
cap under the bus a little bit, okay? In
a very friendly kind of way. Okay, if
like if you if you want to talk about
cloud chasing, whenever the pragmatic
papers are brought up, technically that
is a clout like move, you know what I
mean? Because they're trying to do self
promotion. You're trying to do
self-promotion on top of something,
right? Um because again, uh cloud
chasing shouldn't be just about vibes,
right? It should be about genuine moves,
direct moves to try to get someone to
watch your [__] or to promote your
position or something like that, right?
Getting like promoting the pragmatic
papers every time Kafka is in any call.
Yeah. Like in a way, if you want to make
that the standard, that's fine. But
Kafka would then just be 100% a cloud
chaser, right? Like way more of a cloud
chaser than anybody else. But they would
put CFKA below. They would put Kaka like
like being better than me and Zip and
whatever, right? Just simply because
he's likable, right? But this cloud
chasing allegation is just super weird.
Okay, I'm just saying
involved in fact uh he's not really
>> uh on though they're irredeemable in
just a [__] taking time bomb and
nothing can anyone say on that front
will be anything uh remotely any
defenders of that uh insane behavior
that they have is mental. Okay, mental,
>> dude. Maybe.
>> Wow. Okay.
>> Okay. Are we good? Is it Is it done?
>> You came in here.
>> I have
>> Yeah,
>> we're not holding you hostage.
>> I'm aware you're not holding hostage.
>> Okay. I don't even know what to say,
bro. I don't even know what to say.
>> Cease fire. Cease fire. Cease fire.
Cease fire. Cease fire. We'll let you
get back to your ceasefire. Cease fire.
Cease fire.
>> I was asking if there was anything else.
My god.
>> You guys say or anything.
>> Stop. Ow. This thing's over and it's
more or less resolved.
>> I think it is.
>> No, not me.
>> At least.
>> Oh, with me? Yeah. with Dan. Absolutely
not.
>> Is it really resolved with you after
what you see? Are you like, "Oh, yeah.
This guy's this guy's golden. He's
definitely not a liability." Is that how
you feel?
>> Here's what's happening. I see that it
is affecting him and I'm no longer going
to talk about him.
>> Oh,
>> can I still [__] on Dan or is that
barred? Well, I mean, if we're talking
about tiff or tad, I like I'm assuming
that anything else and DG chat will
still will still like [__] on me and
call me a PDF and stuff. So, honestly,
yeah. I I mean, you can do whatever in
chat. We're just talking about the
streamer here, right? Like, I'm not
brokering a piece between me and like
between Dan and my entire community and
I, right? I'm just talking about from my
standpoint on stream, right? When people
are listening in the background, right?
That is what the peace deal is about.
That That's what the ceasefire is about.
Okay. But you can do whatever the [__]
you want on your own time. Just don't do
anything weird like like actually trying
to spam his DMs or some [__] Don't
don't do [__] like that, please. Okay.
Um but like again, okay. Yeah. I mean,
again, the ceasefire is to me and Dan.
Okay. That's it.
>> Well,
>> okay. That's okay. Cool.
>> You you accept that that it's affecting
you and that we're we're going to be
nice and not talk about because it's
making you upset.
>> I don't think it's it's not making me
upset.
>> So, Mr. Lying.
>> Okay. Asking whether or not someone is
mad is probably not a good move to
deescalate the temperature or to turn
down the temperature. I'm just going to
be real here. Every single time you
always like ask like, "Are you mad? Are
you mad? Are you mad?"
>> First true thing food shops have said
this entire stream. Asking someone if
they're if they're mad isn't a good way
to stop them being mad. First true thing
said all stream.
>> It's probably not the look.
>> No, I think he's mistaken. Damn.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, why don't you correct him?
>> Uh, I don't think I can correct on that
cuz he just has to That's his vibes.
>> We're going to have to agree to disagree
there.
>> Yeah. There's not a disagreement fact
there, Dan. Just
>> Okay. Damn. I know. Okay.
>> All right.
>> They they mutually dislike each other.
This is horrible.
>> So, when you become anti, do you think
you're going to join another anti-fan
community or do you think you'll start
yours up from the ground up? Like, will
you make your own discord or
>> I don't think any other Well, I have a
discord.
>> Remember when I was talking about the
villain machine, the DEG villain
machine?
>> You're um I don't think any would
>> because because once you think about
enough, right, like once you think about
once you want to because you're trying
to manifest, right? Does that make
sense? Like you're trying to manifest
people turning into villains, then
you're going to manifest it, right?
Because once you start asking questions
like that, then they're going to they're
going to see that no no amount of
goodwill that they do is going to be
useful, right? Does that does that make
sense? Like you're basically indicating
to them that they cannot redeem
themselves, that it is impossible for
them to redeem themselves, right?
Because once you start asking statements
like that, I mean it's kind of like
trying to stay in a relationship when
when your partner is being like I guess
verbally abusive to you, right? Like if
they say something like um do you see I
mean why are you why were you like this
like two days ago then? Like do you
think that once you finally like cheat
on me that you'll act like this and
that, right? Like if your dude if your
partner is saying something like oh like
when you finally cheat on me do you
think that um you're going to go with my
ex-boyfriend or something like Yeah.
Yeah. Then then you're trying to create
a villain. It really is it really does
feel like you're trying to create a
villain. Right.
>> People talking about Steam sale. Guys,
did you know that in the Steam sale
right now in the Christmas Steam sale?
Um you can actually get like the entire
Guild Wars 2 all expansions [__] up
until like one expansion ago I think.
for like 45 quid
and all all of them are on sale aside
from the US one. They're all on sale
aside from the US one. So there is it's
you know very easy, very cheap
to get fully into Guild Wars 2 at the
moment. Just to let you guys know,
just to remind you guys, Sid has now
downloaded Guild Wars 2 as far as I
understand. Guiles has been on Guild
Wars 2.
It's be the ball's rolling. Okay. Yep.
Look, this whole games chat is totally
open to Guild Wars 2 discussion. In
fact, it's encouraged. Very important.
Okay.
>> Right. Does that make sense? Yeah.
>> Except me.
>> You're manifesting me.
>> I know. Like a unique one. Oh my god.
You could be kind of aligned pretty
heavily.
>> On course 2 is awesome, dude.
>> Oh,
>> we're going to be doing PvP on cake
later. Okay. While I watch stuff.
>> Okay. The self-promotion kind of thing,
dude. Okay. Yeah. I mean, yeah, I I
would probably say that this is probably
a little bit uh a little bit
hypocritical. Okay. Again, hypocrisy is
a criticism,
>> dude. crying about Dan doing the
redact.dev free advertising on Destiny
stream. Bro,
it's Dan. The rules are different. You
aren't Dan. Like, why do they not get
this, man? It's not like,
you know, you have to be on the Mr. Girl
wave. Okay, you'd have to be on the Mr.
Girl wave. You have to think this should
be ran like a workplace. It's not ran
like a workplace. Dan is Destiny's
friend. The rules are different for Dan.
It's like that symbol. Like there's no
other way of putting it to you.
Like a character attack. Okay. I would
argue that this is hypocritical. Okay.
Especially this this is from today.
Okay. This is from today. All right.
Again, we are playing the game. We are
playing the game. Problem or projection.
Okay. We're playing the game. Problem or
projection. All right. Okay. Good luck,
guys.
>> Kind of like that work.
>> I Oh, man. I'm That is the way that's
kind of like ceasefire. Case fire
tweeting cease fire. That would be the
thing. It would be the Pisco. That would
be the orbit you would go to, right?
>> Um yeah, maybe
>> I have a lot of connections in PC server
because uh I've argued with PC a lot
including over the summer whenever last
had a big disagreement. I had argued
with Pisco for a lot of hours. So I've
already got those connections. I could I
could go there. Um but I don't think
it's going to be over the do thing
because like that's already happened and
I'm still here, right? So I changed my
opinion on that.
>> Wait, hold on. Wait, hold on. Is Zips
being criticized for his connection to
PCO server? Um, okay. I would wager that
this is a little bit hypocritical
considering how Dan is active in the
JSTOK server after after our entire beef
started because I'm pretty sure Dan
talks in there about like about our
beef. Like he he will go in there too.
Okay. Do you guys want to play problem
or projection? All right. Which which
problem? Which is it? Problem or
projection?
>> Yes. But
>> which is it? Oh my lord.
>> All right.
>> Oh no.
>> I have a joke to make.
>> Not good.
>> Okay. I'm listening.
>> Are you like a reverse vampire where you
need our permission to leave?
>> No, cuz D has something to save me. So I
was I was going to say
>> Oh no.
>> Yeah. if there's anything else. But I
think it's time. All right. Thanks for
the chat, guys.
>> See you guys next time. Byebye.
>> Why?
>> We got someone in stream to stream it.
>> This is Okay. All right.
>> No way. They played the stinger rail.
Time to [__] off and play the stinger.
>> Hold on. Let me finish this round park.
>> There's no way,
>> bro. I'm trying to find like some kind
of underground like ladder to the
underground [__] No.
Trying to avoid the drones. I'm not
looking for a fight. Okay, I think I
need to extract her now. I don't I don't
think is ret. All right, guys. I think
that's it.